bonjour à tous je vous souhaite la
bienvenue pour notre réunion de
l'université 133 délocalisée aujourd'hui
à Limoges merci à tous les personnes qui
ont fait le déplacement pour venir dans
cette belle salle et merci à toutes les
personnes qui sont distantes qui nous
suivent sur internet sur facebook
puisque vous savez que ce débat cette
table ronde et retransmises aussi sur
facebook
l'université 133 c'est un petit peu la
Fabrique à idées la Fabrique à penser du
MoDem elle a été lancée en 2019 depuis
et en particulier
augmenté par le covid elle a produit
énormément de réflexion énormément de
table ronde et nous sommes ravis
aujourd'hui de tous nous accueillir à
Limoges pour pouvoir discuter du sens de
du travail je voudrais remercier
Marie-Eve qui se cache à quelque part
qui a été quand même la grande
organisatrice de cette soirée elle a
dépensé beaucoup d'énergie je pense
qu'on peut tous la remercier pour cette
organisation
[Applaudissements]
pour finir je voudrais remercier aussi
la présence de Fabien Robert qui est
aussi un élu régional et qui a la charge
de défédérations modem de toute la
région de sa présence aujourd'hui alors
il est bordelais mais voilà il a fait le
déplacement aussi et c'est important je
vais pas être plus long parce que c'est
pas pour m'écouter que vous êtes venus
mais c'est pour écouter nos intervenants
et je vais donc vous laisser la parole
bonsoir un très très grand merci Vincent
Vincent et Mariève pour votre accueil
très chaleureux à Limoges et c'est nous
qui sommes évidemment très heureux de
découvrir votre ville et puis de
discuter avec vous des enjeux liés au
sens du travail justement précisément
sur un territoire précis avec des
invités qui vont nous
parce que notre réflexion n'est pas du
tout désincarnée ou dans le ciel des
idées mais s'appuie justement sur un
échange d'expérience et donc c'est un
dialogue ouvert qu'on va lancer ensemble
alors ce soir on a donc Patrick Mignola
vice-président du MoDem qui a été
longtemps chef d'entreprise qui connaît
très bien de l'intérieur ce monde de
l'entreprise qui a été chef du groupe
également à l'Assemblée nationale et qui
est à l'initiative de cette de ce cycle
de réflexion sur le sens du travail il
nous expliquera la Genèse Bertrand Le
Guern chef d'entreprise également à
l'étranger notamment qui a déployé des
entreprises un peu partout qui nous
expliquera sa vision extrêmement
humaniste et responsable et justement
qui cherche à mettre de la justice
sociale dans dans l'entreprise et puis
donc de Limoges deux invités extrêmement
impressionnants ça m'y arrive faux qui
est à la fois adjointe au maire de
Limoges chef d'entreprise puisqu'elle
gère 9 de coiffure et agricultrice donc
trois vies ou plus encore et puis Alex
Simons donc qui est président du cluster
des entreprises IT du Limousin et
directeur général délégué démaquina et
qui est donc à la pointe du numérique
donc je laisse Patrick expliquer
pourquoi ce sens du travail pourquoi
justement le travail doit faire sens et
quel sens on peut y mettre et après
j'apporterai des petites précisions
philosophiques rapides de dessus mais
Patrick nous expliquera la oui parce que
je peux vous présenter d'une phrase
Olivia le Boyer qui travaille avec nous
au mouvement démocrates depuis quelques
années et qui est professeur à Sciences
Po et qui est qui est philosophe de
formation vivant un engagement politique
en plus de ces convictions
philosophiques moi d'abord je vais
commencer par vous présenter des excuses
puisque on devait être ici au printemps
dernier et on n'avait pas pu venir pour
une raison assez simple ça me permettra
de présenter en quelques mots c'est que
ça tombait exactement le soir où les
anciens collaborateurs de François
Léotard mon premier patron au ministère
de la Défense c'était retrouvé le soir
de sa sépulture
et se trouvait là un ambassadeur des
États-Unis un ancien ambassadeur des
États-Unis
un écrivain pris Goncourt quelques
anciens ministres et votre serviteur au
parcours bien plus modeste était obligé
évidemment de s'associer à ce moment qui
était toujours un moment
d'intenses émotion évidemment puisque
moi j'ai comme la dit rapidement Olivia
en effet j'ai jamais su choisir entre le
monde de l'entreprise et le monde
politique j'ai toujours fait les deux ce
qui m'a permis d'ailleurs perdant les
législatives au mois de juin dernier de
redevenir entrepreneur être travaillé au
service de des entreprises avec toujours
d'ailleurs le même axe c'est comment on
développe les PME puisque une de mes
obsessions depuis 25 ans d'engagement
public parce que j'ai été élu depuis 95
maire conseiller général conseil
régional député président de métropole
une obsession
c'est comment on peut faire dans ce pays
pour que les TPE deviennent des PME les
PME deviennent des ETI et que la
différence d'autres pays qu'aujourd'hui
on est peut-être en train de dépasser
comme l'Allemagne on soit en capacité de
recréer un tissu économique et
industriel et au fond quand on s'est
rencontré avec avec Bertrand Le Guern
et bah c'est exactement ce constat
commun qu'on a fait lui
qui est dirigé orange et Canal+ en
Pologne je dis que ça juste pour montrer
quel est le l'envergure du personnage et
moi qui avait dirigé des PME dans le
bâtiment et qui essayaient de trouver
des financements à toutes les
entreprises les plus petites possibles
parce que c'est en elle en qui j'ai
confiance et celle qui peuvent le
grandir le plus
de mon côté
et on a on a commencé ce travail
en se disant même si finalement c'était
plus c'était pas vraiment encore le feu
de l'actualité il y a une année de se
dire un
nous pensons que ce sont les entreprises
qui peuvent être au coeur des grandes
mutations numériques
économique financière mais aussi
environnementale et social c'est-à-dire
qu'on le fera pas sans elle
et deux
on a besoin
de redonner un sens et de redonner des
équilibres de justice qui peuvent rendre
à notre pays le la vision qui peut faire
que on n'est pas seulement en train de
créer de la richesse mais on est capable
de donner un sens à la richesse que l'on
crée par la redistribution et par les
enjeux et finalement quelques mois plus
tard de quoi on s'est rendu compte
grâce à beaucoup de réformes et à
beaucoup d'efforts de la majorité à
laquelle j'appartenais même des réformes
parfois jusqu'à l’écurement voir jusqu'à
des fortes contestations sociales dans
la rue ce pays a retrouvé de la
croissance
à retrouver des moyens retrouver est en
train de marcher vers le plein emploi
mais pour autant
il a pas tellement lutté contre la
grande pauvreté et il y avait pas moins
de monde dans les queues des restaurants
du Caire et au contraire
il y a quelques jours on a constaté que
maintenant ils étaient plus nombreux
dans les que des Restaurants du Coeur
parce qu'il y a aussi une problématique
de travailleurs pauvres dans notre pays
qui est venu se sur Ajouter et donc même
quand on est capable de lancer
de la croissance économique de la
réindustrialisation d'un pays
si on sait pas organisé
une nouvelle éthique de l'entreprise et
je sais qu'il y a beaucoup de femmes et
d'hommes d'entreprises et nos deux
invités qu'ont bien voulu être à nos
côtés ont pris ces initiatives là c'est
pour ça que je suis très heureux qu'ils
aient accepté cette invitation
beaucoup de femmes et d'hommes dans le
monde de l'entreprise ont compris que
désormais c'est en c'est en impliquant
les salariés c'est en se donnant des
objectifs environnementaux et sociaux
qu'on serait capable non seulement de
poursuivre cette marche en avant mais
aussi de lui donner un sens et je crois
fondamentalement que c'est bien le monde
économique qui peut contribuer à donner
un sens à la société alors je suis très
heureux qu'on fasse ici à Limoges ce
premier moment décentralisé pour pouvoir
échanger avec vous sur
toutes les formes d'initiative qu'on
peut prendre parce qu'il y aura jamais
un modèle unique mais il s'adaptera
évidemment à chaque secteur d'activité à
chaque type de territoire et je veux
remercier du fond du cœur à la fois
Vincent et Marie-Ève d'avoir organisé ce
moment et je veux dire un mot de
parce que tout à l'heure on a passé un
moment avec le maire de Limoges
et dans l'échange que j'ai eu avec lui
j'ai eu l'impression de retrouver des
gens qui étaient vraiment de la famille
politique à laquelle j'appartiens depuis
toujours
c'est à dire des personnalités qui
brillent par leur
engagement profond qui sont pas là que
pour se montrer
qui veulent pas juste être mais qui
veulent faire
qui propose des idées qui savent
travailler avec des gens qui ont pas les
mêmes convictions que et moi je les
remercie parce que quand je me promène
un peu partout en France je suis très
heureux de trouver cette identité
politique là qui est exactement
l'inverse de l'horrible image politique
que parfois on voit nous être présentés
à la télévision puis je veux saluer
évidemment
Fabien qui a un compagnon de route
et au moment où moi ma route est pas
très loin de s'arrêter je serais très
heureux que la sienne soit encore très
longue à vos côtés et donc voilà je
voulais simplement lui dire ça donc je
vais laisser la parole à Bertrand pour
que ben non d'abord à Olivia qui va
poser comment le fait à chaque fois en
quelques minutes un cadre philosophique
puis ensuite en quelques minutes un
cadre d'objectifs politiques
environnementaux économique sociaux par
Bertrand et puis surtout avoir les
témoignages
des entrepreneurs qui sont là pour
qu'ensuite on puisse converser très
librement avec vous parce que j'ai le
sentiment que on a encore beaucoup de
choses à inventer dans ce monde
politique
merci beaucoup Patrick alors en effet je
vais être très brève je vais lancer
puisque la philosophie c'est surtout
l'étonnement surtout quelques questions
quelques citations finalement pour
réfléchir un peu ensemble il y a une
citation du philosophe Alain que j'aime
bien qui dit du travail on a fait
supplice et punition mais c'est qu'on le
sépare du Spectacle du Monde et
effectivement c'est un peu ce qui nous a
frappé au moment des débats autour de la
réforme des retraites d'un seul coup on
a eu l'impression qu'il y avait comme un
une crispation autour de la question de
l'âge comme s'il y avait un moment au
travail et un moment d'après travail
dans la vie une césure très nette
assignable à un chiffre alors que
finalement le travail se comprend dans
toutes les dimensions de la vie aux
différentes étapes lorsqu'on se projette
au moment des études
lorsqu'on change d'orientation
professionnelle lorsqu'on rebiffure que
et puis effectivement le temps de la
retraite ce qui n'est pas pour tous un
temps uniforme on peut s'y consacrer à
du bénévolat on peut continuer une vie
associative on peut désirer travailler
corps et donc effectivement se couperait
comme si le travail devait être conçu
sur un mode de lorriste a finalement un
petit peu empêché les débats à ce moment
de se concentrer sur la question du sens
le sens pour qui pourquoi alors le sens
on peut le voir dans plusieurs
dimensions le sens du travail dans son
utilité dans la société le sens au sein
d'un collectif et le sens au sens
d'épanouissement personnel que chacun
peut ou veut ou souhaite y trouver donc
comment raccorder cela pour le coup Anna
Arendt et peut-être la philosophe qui a
le plus détaillé la question des
différents types d'activités en
distinguant le travail
œuvre et actions en montrant qu'on
pouvait les combiner et que précisément
l'action était ce moment où les hommes
se reliaient entre par leur travail et
que le moment de l'oeuvre c'est le
moment où on produit alors elle
distinguait différents types de métiers
selon qu'on produit quelque chose de
consommables ou quelque chose de durable
donc par exemple du pain ou une table en
disant finalement ce qui sépare le pain
d'une table et plus différents que ce
qui sépare le métier de boulanger du
métier de menuisier et donc toute une
réflexion sur finalement ce qu'on
produit dans quel sens et surtout pour
quel émancipation donc comment parvenir
à ce que le travail soit relié à l'idée
de liberté davantage qu'à celle de
contrainte ce qu'on a coutume de dire de
plus en plus ces dernières années que
travail ça vient de tripalium du latin
qui veut dire supplice mais en fait
c'est un peu contesté comme étymologie
ça peut aussi venir de traps qui vient
de poutre et qui veut dire aussi un peu
entraver et contrainte mais le travail
c'est aussi le travail du c'est un
instrument du maréchal ferrant qui
soigne les chevaux donc on peut aussi
concevoir cela sur un mode un peu plus
dynamique de là aussi quelque chose qui
pousse à avancer donc juste une petite
réflexion supplémentaire sur la question
du temps parce que dans nos soirées
la cinquième soirée qu'on consacre au
thème avec Patrick et Bertrand on a
beaucoup insisté sur les mutations du
monde du travail sur les nouveaux
métiers sur tout ce qui bouge et sur
cette accélération de la société alors
pour le coup c'est Rosa le philosophe
qui a beaucoup écrit sur l'accélération
du monde moderne et qui dit que une des
denrées finalement les plus précieuses
les plus rares et sans doute les plus
chers ça va devenir le temps parce que
le temps va devenir aussi précieux que
le pétrole est constitué une manne
finalement que l'on a de moins en moins
on a l'impression que tout va de plus en
plus vite alors c'est une impression
parce que dans le même temps on va tous
à la même vitesse on ira tous la semaine
prochaine ensemble à la même vitesse
mais on est soumis à cette impression
d'accélération en permanente donc
impression stress burn out à Sciences Po
il y a eu notamment parce que donc très
très vite alors là en une seule minute
nous on parle du sens du travail depuis
plusieurs mois et on voit que pas mal de
publications sortent pile en ce moment
dessus donc il y a notamment un livre de
Thomas coutreau et Coralie Perez qui
s'appelle redonner du sens au travail
une aspiration révolutionnaire qui est
sortie cette année aux éditions des
liens qui libèrent et qui incite
beaucoup sur les liens entre le travail
et la santé l'impact sur la santé et en
insistant ce qui va rejoindre nos
préoccupations sur le fait que
finalement pourquoi on devient on a fait
des burn out on se mit on se ronge
intérieurement lorsqu'on est pas bien
dans son travail c'est surtout lorsqu'on
ne comprend pas lorsqu'on est soumis
finalement à des décisions absurdes ou
qu'on a l'impression que les décisions
viennent d'en haut sans avoir été
consultés concerté donc on revient à
cette question qu'on va développer
ensemble de comment mieux associer les
salariés à leur entreprise comment faire
en sorte qu'ils sentent peut-être une
appartenance parce qu'on sait que de
moins en moins il y a un sentiment
d'identification ou d'appartenance à un
travail mais en tous les cas qui s'y
sentent bien et que ils aient
l'impression que les changements
n'arrivent pas de manière absurde et
brutales et sans avoir été consulté
d'autres
contributions à ce à ce laboratoire font
état de la mobilité des jeunes de leur
plus grande exigences aussi sur le plan
écologique ça on va en parler pas mal
avec Bertrand on a vu récemment les
ingénieurs d'AgroParisTech notamment
dire qu'ils ne travailleraient pas à
n'importe quel prix pour n'importe quel
entreprise qu'il y a effectivement les
compétences qu'ils ont ils souhaitent
les mettre au service d'un intérêt
général ou d'un ou d'un idéal donc une
plus grande exigence peut-être qui se
manifeste on travaille pas à n'importe
quel prix même si on travaille pour de
l'argent ce qu'on voit aussi beaucoup il
y a des travaux de Cleia ziznic
notamment sur le bonheur qui est assis
sur le fait que l'argent ne fait pas le
bonheur certes mais quand même voilà la
question du salaire l'argent est tabou
en France on en parle souvent
difficilement souvent peu il faut en
parler justement cette question de
meilleure équité salariale d'une
imposition plus juste des entreprises
toutes ces questions ne peuvent pas être
simplement éludés elle compte évidemment
énormément dans cette question de
distribution de la valeur et toutes les
questions d'actionnariat d'intéressement
de participation
jouer évidemment de manière importante
sur le moral que chacun a dans le
travail qu'il a effectuer naturellement
sur la question de la vitesse juste cité
Daniel Cohen qui nous a quitté très
récemment et qui disait l'économiste qui
disait qu'effectivement avant un salarié
qui travaillait chez Ford ou Renault
savait de manière quasi certaine qu'il
terminerait sa carrière dans cette
entreprise alors qu'aujourd'hui
quelqu'un qui commence chez Microsoft ne
sait pas où il va terminer ou c'est
rarement voir pas du tout où il va la
terminer donc cette plus grande
incertitude nous on fait le pari que
c'est une forme de liberté qu'il faut
évidemment accompagner et à sortir d'une
exigence forte de justice sociale je
laisse Bertrand nous expliquer merci
Olivia j'ai même rebondir sur ce que tu
viens de dire je pense que aujourd'hui
un jeune qui commence à travailler dans
une entreprise entreprise c'est il a
même la certitude qu'il ne terminera pas
dans cette entreprise c'est on est on
est là de ce point de vue là on est
passé d'un extrême à l'autre ok c'est
c'est une structure du monde du travail
qui a totalement changé donc pour je
vais juste faire quelques minutes sur la
comment on a construit ce cycle de débat
et surtout qu'elle constat nous sommes
partis au début donc effectivement
depuis
quelques années et maintenant les
chiffres macroéconomiques en France sont
absolument indéniables l'économie
française a retrouvé une une véritable
croissance il y a toutes sortes
d'indicateurs qui sont
ouverts et qui résulte de choix de
certaines réformes qui ont été faites
mais aussi de qualité intrinsèque de de
l'économie française de aussi bien
système éducatif qui qui est assez
faiblesse mais enfin qui qui sait
produire de l'ingénieur des gens des
gens qualifiés dans dans toutes sortes
de domaines et ça ce sont des critères
qui sont clairement identifiés par les
investisseurs au moment où ils
choisissent devenir un de venir investir
en France donc les sur
comment dire tout ce qui a été fait au
niveau macroéconomique il y a pas de
doute que les effets sont là
en revanche
en fait et
on peut prendre comme critère la France
reste la cinquième ou sixième économie
du monde c'est indéniable maintenant si
vous regardez niveau
microéconomique alors là les choses sont
beaucoup moins
reluisantes et je vais juste citer un un
indicateur par exemple au sein de l'OCDE
la France c'est la 22e ou 23e nation en
ce qui concerne le salaire moyen donc on
est vraiment on a vraiment une un effet
de divergence en ce moment qui
va manifestement devient de plus en plus
pénible et je vais pas revenir sur les
crises qu'il y a eu depuis quelques
années sur les tensions qui a eu autour
de la réforme des retraites etc parce
que évidemment toutes ces tensions
sont aussi liées à toutes sortes de
manipulations qui qui sont faites OK
pour vous présenter certaines des
initiatives enfin la réalité c'est que
il y a bien une divergence très
importante entre des perspectives
économiques qui sont effectivement
très intéressantes et une réalité
économique au jour le jour pour
un grand nombre d'employés qui sont au
moins
frustrantes voire parfois désespérantes
c'est quand même
hallucinant de penser que au cours des
dernières années on a un taux de chômage
qui baisse et un nombre de travailleurs
pauvres qui augmentent c'est c'est tout
à fait
comment dire déconcertant donc on a on a
essayé aussi de se poser la question
parce que sur la sur le domaine autant
la partie macroéconomique les réformes
très centralisées sont assez efficaces
autant sur la partie microéconomique et
donc qui essaye d'influer sur ce qu'il
se passe dans 4 millions d'entreprises
c'est ça c'est 4 millions d'entreprises
en France et voilà c'est évident que
c'est pas c'est pas un gouvernement qui
décide que tel ou tel personne va avoir
son salaire augmenté tout ça ça se passe
dans l'entreprise et là c'est aussi un
des éléments qu'on a qu'on a essayé de
vraiment sur lequel on a essayé
s'appuyer c'est de dire et si on
cherchait des solutions qui
profite au maximum des effets que l'on
peut obtenir en ayant des réflexions et
des changements au sein des entreprises
des changements négociés qui permettent
à aux employés de s'approprier ces
changements et qui au bout du compte
permettent de générer vraiment des
changements à grande échelle je vais
pour terminer
si tu es un exemple qui m'a moi
interloqué
et qui prouve à quel point
une somme de petits efforts peut-être
vraiment peut donner un effet absolument
impressionnant on a tous entendu parler
de cet hiver dernier de la nécessité de
faire des économies d'énergie
et si quelqu'un avait dit
au vu de l'improvisation de la fin
d'année sur tout le monde doit faire un
petit effort pour économiser mettre un
pull etc je vais pas faire de
plaisanterie déplacée mais la réalité
c'est que
au vu de l'improvisation
c'est assez c'était assez difficile de
penser qu'on allait avoir vraiment des
effets significatifs la réalité c'est
que avec ces appels là on a réussi à
faire baisser la consommation d'énergie
en France de 10%. c'est des chiffres
astronomiques astronomiques c'est
absolument je pense que si quelqu'un
avait dit on va obtenir 10% de réduction
de la consommation d'énergie avant il
aurait été la cible de comment dire de
plaisanterie vraiment très désagréable
quoi et la réalité c'est que c'est le
cas ça montre à quel point en fait la
somme de petits efforts
est une est une source de de changement
absolument fascinante moi je suis
personnellement convaincu que au sein de
ces 4 millions d'entreprises c'est bien
là qu'il y aura des changements sur
l'égalité des salaires femmes hommes sur
les comment dire des
au moins une baisse de certaines
inégalités salariale et puis qu'on va
pouvoir trouver des des solutions pour
que les gens se sentent les employés se
sentent plus impliqués sur le devenir de
leur entreprise c'est des choses qui
existent mais malheureusement qui
n'existe pas de façon
généralisée Patrick mentionnait
aujourd'hui le cet exemple il y a que 5%
des entreprises qui qui offrent des
systèmes de participation à leurs
employés
ça montre à quel point il y a encore 95%
qui ne font pas ok mais c'est
intéressant de voir que les 5% qu'il
offre n'ont pas mis la clé sous la porte
donc tout ça tout ça est assez est assez
optimiste mais il y a il y a du travail
et puis surtout pour finir c'est clair
que c'est pas au travers de nouvelles
lois qu'on va qu'on va résoudre il faut
absolument que les pouvoirs publics
arrivent à se positionner en tant que
régulateur et non plus en tant que
législateur qui dit voilà vous avez à
faire ça à droite à gauche ça ne
marchera pas pour pour que 4 millions
d'entreprises se mobilisent et et aborde
ces sujets là voilà
merci oui alors donc je vais me
présenter puisque effectivement donc
j'ai 9 salons de coiffure 52
collaborateurs qui travaillent avec moi
dans mes salons et je suis parallèlement
à ça exploitant agricole dans les mondes
blonds je vous invite à aller voir c'est
un endroit magnifique
où j’élève des bobins bovins viande
puisque en Limousin on a des vaches
magnifiques des chevaux de sport et puis
je fais également des céréales et depuis
une année je me suis lancée dans la
culture de bambou géant pour faire des
matériaux de construction des meubles
voilà parce que je crois beaucoup à tout
cela et ça c'est mon volet c'est un peu
ma passion voilà alors il y aurait
beaucoup de choses à dire moi j'ai envie
de parler de choses très concrètes parce
que je ne suis pas j'ai pas fait de
philosophie et ma philosophie à moi
c'est le matin quand je me lève de me
dire comment on fait pour continuer à
avancer dans mes entreprises dans mes
petites entreprises et je vais rebondir
sur que vous avez dit j'aimerais
énormément qu'on fasse confiance aux
dirigeants de d'entreprises de ce pays
alors effectivement il y en a certains à
qui faut pas faire confiance mais je
pense que la plupart sont des gens
bienveillants et des gens qui ont envie
de réussir et de faire réussir leurs
entreprises et il faut absolument faire
confiance à ces entrepreneurs là parce
que effectivement quand je vois que
l'État veut se mêler de tout et nous dit
il faut mettre un pull avec un col roulé
ou là c'est insupportable et concernant
les entreprises c'est aussi
insupportable de s'entendre dire que
peut-être on va faire une loi pour dire
qu'il va falloir travailler 4 jours
plutôt que 5 laissez-nous tranquille
foot et nous la paix on sait si on doit
travailler 4 jours ou pas il y a des
entreprises qui peuvent le faire ou pas
il y a des salariés qui en ont envie ou
pas et je pense que l'entreprise en
lui-même l'entrepreneur en lui-même et
les salariés co-construisent ensemble ce
qui se doit se faire dans l'entreprise
et qui permet d'avoir un résultat qui
gagnant-gagnant gagnant pour
l'entreprise parce que son entreprise il
n'y a pas d'emploi il y a mais gagnant
pour le salarié parce que s'il y a pas
de salarié il y a pas d'entreprise c'est
quand même bête comme chou c'est une
évidence c'est une question de bon sens
le bon sens paysan auquel je tiens tant
et j'ai pas besoin qu'on me fasse une
loi pour me dire il faut qu'on travaille
4 jours alors tout n'est pas rose ne
croyez pas que je suis de la chef
d'entreprise miraculeuse voilà moi aussi
je rencontre des difficultés mais j'ai
malgré tout des entreprises des
collaborateurs qui sont avec moi depuis
30 ans en coiffure ça reste quand même
un exploit j'ai aussi des jeunes qui qui
zappent qui vont qui viennent
j'en retire quoi comme conclusion c'est
que alors pour moi c'est beaucoup de
travail et plus ça va plus c'est
beaucoup de travail parce que il faut
faire preuve d'agilité je pense que
l'entrepreneur actuel en 2023 il doit
savoir faire preuve d'agilité alors moi
on me demande comment je fais pour faire
tout ce que je fais moi j'ai pas
l'impression que je travaille j'ai
l'impression que tout ça c'est un jeu et
j'y trouve beaucoup de plaisir dire je
ne fais pas de sport alors parfois pour
rigoler je dis tout le monde je fais pas
de sport mais je fais du surf tous les
jours parce que tous les jours je surf
sur ce qui va se passer pas se passer et
comment ça va se passer voilà c'est ça
mon sport au quotidien dans mes
entreprises je crois qu'on est tous un
petit peu comme ça quand on dirige de
l'humain parce que il se passe des
choses qui sont un peu imprévisibles il
faut aussi
énormément débriefé expliqué moi je
recrute tous les ans énormément de
jeunes et j'adore ça parce que je pense
que là on a une jeunesse extraordinaire
alors on les critique beaucoup
mais quand on prend le temps de discuter
que de leur expliquer les choses ils
sont très créatifs ils ont des idées
parfois absolument farfelues mais qui
quand au final on se met un peu de Sion
on peut trouver et déboucher sur quelque
chose de bien mais ils ont besoin qu'on
les écoute ils ont besoin qu'on leur
explique ils ont besoin qu'on débrief
ensemble ils ont besoin de choses
parfois
simple pour leur dire mais pourquoi tu
as voulu être coiffeur et parfois je
leur dis ça mais oui mais je me suis pas
posé la question voilà et quand on
arrive à ça et ben on arrive à écrire
des histoires et de et de belles
histoires parce que ils ont aussi de
nombreuses qualités et que je j'ai envie
de dire qu'effectivement on change de
logiciel il y a des tas de choses
nouvelles c'est très compliqué mais
malgré tout on a une jeunesse qui a
aussi envie de réussir ils ont aussi
envie d'avoir une grosse voiture ils ont
aussi envie d'avoir des belles vacances
ils ont aussi envie d'avoir une jolie
maison et il faut arrêter de penser que
ils sont tous dans les quartiers en
train de tout casser c'est faux c'est
c'est une poignée de jeunes qui font
n'importe quoi c'est une poignée de
jeunes qui vole pas le coup et on ne
sait pas donner les bonnes réponses
parce que ils nous font la guerre bah
nous on devrait répondre aussi en
faisant la guerre sur ces personnes là
mais les autres les autres tous ceux que
je croise à la Mission Locale de Limoges
j'en suis la présidente depuis trois ans
je peux vous assurer que quand on passe
du temps mais c'est sûr que c'est de la
dentelle il faut faire jeune par jeune
et bien on arrive à avoir de bons
résultats et avoir des jeunes qui qui
s'épanouissent et on en trouve un et on
le met dans la bonne entreprise et on a
aussi bien débriefé que le chef
d'entreprise ou avec le DRH et voilà
mais tout ça ça prend beaucoup de temps
mais bon il faut croire
grand merci Alexis
bonsoir
donc justement sur sur ma personne et
imagina donc comme chacun le sait je
pense je précise d'une entreprise à
Limoges qui fait 77 salariés au sein
d'une entité qui en fait 1500 niveaux
européens et mondial qui ont fait 70 000
c'est juste dire j'ai des jeux blancs on
a commencé le numérique en 1995 dans un
placard de la technopole Esther
et aujourd'hui je préside un réseau
d'entreprises numériques en Limousin qui
fait à peu près 200 entités il y a un
label French tech avec à peu près 90
startups qui s'égayent aussi autour de
tout ça
et c'est un point sur lequel je veux
insister parce que
on ne peut pas faire tout seul moi je
crois énormément et c'est le sens de bon
implication dans ces organisations à
l'action collective et je ne crois pas
je n'ai jamais vu d'ailleurs je vais
être un peu dur je n'ai jamais vu les
puissances publiques à travers par
rapport au changement et il pourra voir
mais je crois que Bertrand aussi avoir
vécu toute la ce qu'on a appelé la
révolution numérique qui est terminée
d'ailleurs l'État a toujours été en
retard alors là on arrive à peu près à
ce que la Commission européenne soit à
peu près à l'heure en terme de
régulation à peu près à peu près oui oui
c'est bien c'est bien mais moi je n'ai
jamais vu j'ai toujours vu la puissance
publique plutôt prendre acte de choses
qui s'était déjà produites
et donc
[Musique]
c'est au sein des entreprises et au sein
des mouvements d'entreprise et il faut
qu'on se fasse preuve de de des tickets
de valeurs qu'il faut qu'on anticipe ça
et qu'on digère ça et c'est pas quand
les lois arrivent que que ça doit se
passer il faut déjà qu'on ait fait le
boulot avant en fait voilà alors
pour prendre un exemple parce que je
voulais en parler on a évoqué le
la sobriété le climat tous les enjeux
autour de ça
en toute sincérité je suis très
sceptique sur l'engagement même y
compris des jeunes a réellement au-delà
des de l'aspect de façade à être
impliqué dedans et il y a des tonnes de
chiffres là-dedans
sur le numérique on a un plan de
sobriété on a signé avec le ministre un
plan de décarbonation de l'industrie
numérique donc il y a un engagement
collectif très fort mais après la vérité
c'est que quand on descend sur le
terrain dans le bureau d'un chef
d'entreprise est-ce que c'est une
priorité sur la table pas du tout
est-ce que les salariés sont prêts
abandonner leur voiture pour venir sur
d'autres formes au bureau
c'est pas certain donc mais ça on le
sait tous
l'effort il est souvent attendu à côté
et pas pour soi-même alors oui il y a
des élèves ingénieurs qui aimeraient
bien arriver dans des boîtes qui ont des
engagements qui montrent qu'elles font
des choses etc et qui ont plutôt envie
de se raccrocher parce qu'ils ont pas
envie de dire à leurs copains qui sont
qui sont des 25 entreprises qui font mal
les choses mais il faut être prudent et
moi ce que ce que ce que je dis c'est
que il ne faut pas se laisser
enfumer par les ondes par les discours
collectifs etc le cheminement individuel
est beaucoup plus difficile
sur l'emploi je vais raconter une petite
histoire le développement d'imaginat et
une partie d'ailleurs pas que nous une
partie des acteurs numériques qui sont
développés ici en s'est développé ici
pour une raison assez étonnante alors je
disais une époque à certains élus que
Limoges c'était du Niort
c'était d'une lumière Shore on avait des
salariés on était collés au cul de très
beaux
viviers de recrutement
l'université les écoles qui d'ailleurs
attention je dis des choses violentes
qui d'ailleurs surproduisaient du
diplômé par rapport à ce que le bassin
d'emploi était capable de prendre
magnifique on avait plus qu'à trier à
prendre les meilleures voyez ce que je
veux dire mais on était dans la même
stratégie que des grands groupes ont été
et s'aimés dans des géographies pas si
lointaines que ça parce qu'après les
salaires étaient modérés et c'est vrai
que les gens restent les gens
s'installent les gens on a on a moins
fort taux de de sortie des personnels
par eux-mêmes les gens s'installent et
restent ici d'ailleurs soit il est en
passant dans un moment où
la faculté à se loger
est en vrai problème être dans un dans
une géographie où les gens trouvent à se
loger
en locatif comme en bien ça va compter
je connais des j'ai des confrères pour
pas au Pays Basque qui qui refuse des
gens qui veulent venir bosser parce que
les gens n'arrivent pas à se loger voilà
donc c'est le truc qui arrive
donc on avait fait le pari de ça et ça
on s'étonnait avec des confrères qui eux
faisaient du vrai Niort en Roumanie par
exemple de dire regarde à Limoges on
fait pareil on est compétitif alors ça
c'est fini
c'est fini parce que depuis le covid le
télétravail est devenu la norme dans mon
industrie
que maintenant tout le monde recrute
en subissant en tout cas c'est le
salarié qui dicte sa loi en disant moi
j'habite à l'endroit je vais continuer à
travailler et ce sera en télétravail et
vous le voulez et ben vous faites comme
ça et ça marche parce qu'on sait
travailler aussi en mode distanciel
comme ça donc du coup le la grille des
salaires s'est aligné et s’aligné sur
quoi sur la grille des salariés de
France puisque 50% de numérique est en
Île-de-France donc c'est 50% du
numérique qui a dicté sa loi et donc
aujourd'hui un collaborateur limougeot
il est chassé par une boîte parisienne
qui lui proposera 25% plus de salaire
qu'il a ici à moins que vous ne fassiez
l'effort de monter le niveau pour être à
l'échelle ce qu'on a fait
et vous même vous pouvez évidemment
aller taper dans dans ce des autres et
ainsi de suite
donc ce qui veut dire que si vous n'êtes
pas en situation dans votre business
d'impacter la montée de salaire
relativement à vos marges et à vos coûts
vous êtes plus là en fait voilà et ça se
produit donc la marche du monde je
raconte des choses qui se passent dans
ce n'était jamais entendu parler mais
qui qui ont lieu en fait qui sont sous
nos yeux voilà où on entend des
histoires incroyables de de moi j'ai
entendu des confrères bordelais
expliquer qui se faisait piller par de
cannibalisme de boîte qui arrivait qui
mangeaient les autres d'à côté et
c'était les salariés parce que le
numérique est un métier est un marché de
main d'oeuvre une forme nous sommes un
une industrie de main d'oeuvre le
Saint-Ex dit qu'on est de l'industrie de
la connaissance je crois que c'est ça le
terme donc on fait de la main d'oeuvre
alors à haut niveau de salaire en valeur
ajoutée à tout ce que vous voulez mais
on est ça
et alors pour faire ça je reviens sur
l'histoire du Niort les jeunes
puisque ça ne marche des histoires que
je vous raconte que parce que on va
faire le pari de la jeunesse donc le
choix très tôt de l'apprentissage
pour aller chercher les jeunes le plus
loin possible à l'intérieur du système
éducatif notamment parce que par exemple
sur les jeunes filles on va les perdre
elles vont même si elles sont bonnes en
sciences au collège elles vont faire
autre chose donc il faut descendre très
profond à l'intérieur du système
éducatif pour les convaincre de de
d'aller faire des carrières
scientifiques et de venir vers nous plus
tard les stages de 3e c'est pas juste
pour la pour la galerie ça on les revoit
plus tard c'est une vérité et les faire
grandir les faire rentrer dans
l'entreprise faire rentrer dans ce
collectif parce que une entreprise c'est
un collectif
et on parle de marque employeur et de
toutes ces sortes de choses mais
fondamentalement enfin vous le savez
tous quand
on dit souvent à un collaborateur qui
part il quitte pas une entreprise et qui
est un manager voilà mais c'est si les
gens restent c'est parce qu'ils sont
bien tant collectif entre eux et même
dans les grandes entreprises et
collectif de proximité des gens qui
travaillent entre eux et on retrouve ça
je reviens sur le télétravail parce que
ceux qui sont en télétravail qui ont
décidé de dire ah mais je suis bien chez
moi je vais continuer à travailler chez
moi bah au bout d'un moment ils
reviennent parce que ils ont besoin de
prendre le café avec les autres et de
discuter donc il se passe beaucoup de
choses autour de ça et je crois qu'il y
a une notion du vivre ensemble à
l'intérieur des des salariés
d'entreprise qui sont en train de se
réinventer entre eux et qui vous
interpelle par rapport à ça et moi ce
que je vais recevoir c'est que c'est
moins des des grandes choses type
effectivement la RSE mais c'est quoi la
RSE c'est effectivement c'est des
engagements mais c'est presque des cases
à cocher enfin une checklist qu'on fait
parce qu'il faut être sur le marché et
qu'il faut satisfaire à ses obligations
je suis je suis cash
oui le climat et les initiatives qu'on
prend pour être plus sobre etc etc mais
combien il y en a que ça intéresse
vraiment à l'intérieur après ils ont
envie d'être fiers de la boîte dans
lequel ils sont parce que il y a du
succès parce qu'il y a des aventures
communes parce que ensemble ils vont
gagner quelque chose ou qu'ils
réussissent à faire quelque chose et ça
se voit parce que quand à un moment
donné il y a il y a une personne un peu
clé qui sort mais ça suit voilà il s'en
vont et là ils sont effectivement ils
satisfasse à ce qui ne faisait pas avant
à un plus fort salaire ailleurs de
meilleures conditions de travail des
avantages en nature etc mais on peut
arriver si on a une une vraie vivre
ensemble si on est attentif à ce que les
gens vivent bien entre eux au travail et
les conditions de travail c'est très
importantes ce point de vue là la
faculté la confiance qu'on leur donne
typiquement nous chez Emakina il y a pas
d'horaire
il y a pas d'horreur
il débute quand il vaut à la fin il faut
qu'ils aient fait le boulot qu'ils
avaient dit qu'il ferait dans la semaine
point et on leur fait confiance et ça
fonctionne mais alors après c'est des
ingénieurs c'est des gens qui ont fait
des longues études c'est ce que vous
voulez c'est pas n'importe quel type de
salarié non plus mais il y a ce vivre
ensemble il y a cette esprit collectif
qu'ils ont fabriqué entre eux et c'est
une contribution à ce qui est
l'entreprise je dis ça c'est moins
dirigeant qui décide dans une réunion de
dire que les valeurs entreprises c'est
ça ça que plutôt de regarder les
salariés comment est-ce qu'on porte pour
dire voilà nous sommes ceci en fait on
est une équipe voilà c'est très
important
dans ces deux témoignages vraiment
passionnants et en effet confiance et
liberté c'est jumeaux ça va complètement
ensemble oui si on permettait en France
on n'est pas bon là-dessus on fera on
n'était pas bon on a une tendance à être
trop directif et trop verticale et puis
un mot sur le management parce que c'est
la faute c'est le défaut français c'est
pas parce que vous êtes nommé du jour au
lendemain manager de quelque chose que
vous l'êtes c'est un vrai métier c'est
des vrais compétences ça s'apprend et il
y a trop on a le niveau du management on
est mauvais en France là dessus et ça ne
marche pas donc il faut il faut vraiment
se remettre en question de ce point de
vue là et combien il y a de mauvais
chefs mauvais mauvais mauvais
interlocuteurs qui sont maintenus et des
gens surpris parce que je dis ça parce
que c'est quelque chose qui a été craqué
depuis très très longtemps aux
États-Unis cette idée en France que
votre réussite dans la carrière sera
d'être manager vous-même
alors moi enfin j'ai eu deux expériences
comme ça avec des salariés qui m'ont dit
moi je veux être chef voilà je veux être
chef d'équipe ou est-ce que vous voulez
ok bon on va essayer voilà vas-y et au
bout d'un an on les a revu ils étaient
en souffrance ça marchait pas leurs
collègues tirait la gueule si je peux me
permettre donc on l'a dit écoute c'est
ce qu'on va faire tu vas revenir ou
téter parce que la voix de l'expertise
et pas moins bonne que la voix du
management et chez nous vous gagnerez
autant en suivant la voie de l'expertise
dans votre carrière que si vous faisiez
du management je vais je vais rebondir
sur deux trois choses qui ont été dites
alors la dernière à propos du management
malheureusement ça c'est absolument
indéniablement une une faiblesse
en France être manager c'est un statut
alors que ça n'a absolument aucun sens
ce n'est pas un statut c'est une
véritable compétence il y a des gens qui
sont capables de l'être et d'autres qui
ne sont pas et malheureusement dans la
immense majorité on devient manager
parce que c'est une façon de donner une
augmentation et que quand il y a
quelqu'un qui travaille depuis 5 ou 10
ans bah il faut en faire quelque chose
quoi voilà et c'est ça c'est vraiment
n'importe quoi ça c'est clair que c'est
une c'est quelque chose qui devra
évoluer mais là-dessus je voudrais
rebondir sur maintenant deux trois
choses que vous avez dit c'est
une évidence vous venez de citer
l'exemple de de votre secteur ou vous
n'avez pas de d'horaire ok mais
voilà mais c'est possible dans votre
secteur ok vous
vous pouvez pas faire ça les clients ils
viennent de telle heure à telle heure ok
donc les horaires c'est une véritable
nécessité voilà et ça montre à quel
point toute cette dimension
microéconomique elle ne elle n'a de
chances de d'évoluer d'être que si on
rend vraiment
on amène ses évolutions au niveau de
l'entreprise c'est vraiment là que ça se
joue alors certaines choses peuvent être
discutées au niveau des branches mais en
fait c'est vraiment dans l'entreprise
que ces choses là doivent être
doivent pouvoir se s'approprier et c'est
comme ça aussi qu'on changera l'image du
dialogue social c'est en
s'assurant que ça devienne vraiment une
solution systémique que ces choses là se
font dans l'entreprise que petit à petit
on redonnera du sens à ce mot qui est le
dialogue social qui malheureusement
pendant pas mal d'années a été vidé de
son sens parce que trop de choses
voulaient on voulait on voulait régler
trop de choses de façon centralisée ok
donc c'est vraiment intéressant de de
vous entendre c'est exactement ça vient
illustrer vraiment un des comment dire
un des points de un des une des
directions de des travaux qu'on a qu'on
a essayé de faire justement en
comprenant bien que là pour le coup
c'est dans l'entreprise que ça peut se
passer et pas ailleurs
je vais ajouter une phrase
ce que je viens d'entendre et qui est
génial c'est ce que les Latins
appelaient déjà la fexio-sociatis c'est
au fond l'identité d'une entreprise
l'envie qu'on a de s'y engagé l'envie
qu'on a dit progresser d'y rester ce qui
fait que des fournisseurs nous sont un
peu plus fidèles et parfois plus clément
des clients viennent vers nous plutôt
qu'ailleurs c'est exactement cette
identité d'entreprise
ne sont pas aussi vertueuses et le gros
défaut de la puissance publique pour moi
qui a été de part et d'autre de la
barrière c'est effectivement de vouloir
faire les trucs à votre place
et comme forcément il y a toujours 10 ou
15% de mauvais élèves c'est les flics
sont pas sympas parce qu'il y a 10% de
chauffeur sur la route en fait voilà
c'est comme ça que ça se passe or
ça va se jouer maintenant
parce que vous savez tout ce que sont
déjà les obligations
RSE qui ont été modérément appliqués
parce que la série Chris successives en
fait que bon il fallait pas en rajouter
encore
finalement la taxe sodomie verte
européenne est passée assez crème parce
que comme il y a eu la crise ukrainienne
bah tout le monde a dû faire des efforts
en matière d'énergie donc finalement
tout le monde sait convaincu qu'il
fallait faire ses efforts là mais
devons-nous on a un champ que vous avez
en tête vous comme chef d'entreprise à
travers ou fédérations professionnelles
c'est le champ de la taxonomie sociale
européenne après la taxonie verte et si
vous avez craint la technologie verte
vous pouvez craindre plus encore la
taxonomie sociale si elle est décidé
d'en haut et s'appliquait tous
uniformément quel que soit les secteurs
et quel que soit les territoires parce
que vous venez de démontrer l'un et
l'autre que vous aviez un affection
sociététisme où vous avez pas besoin
forcément que la puissance publique
s'occupe de vous pour vous dire ce que
vous devez faire tout en étant
extrêmement différent dans votre
démarche dans vos réflexes et dans vos
rapports avec les salariés
nous devons inventer
une identité économique européenne qui
soit construite par la base
c'est à dire exactement l'inverse de la
taxonomie verte c'est pour ça que
Bertrand et ses ce sur quoi je
rebondissais à raison de dire que ça va
nous permettre de réinventer le dialogue
social en fait de donner un autre rôle
au corps intermédiaire aux fédérations
professionnelles au syndicat de salariés
et aux syndicats patronaux
parce que sinon
les choses ont déjà été assez largement
pré écrite par la Commission européenne
et avec des objectifs qui sont tout à
fait vertueux quelle va être
l'impact l'empreinte de l'entreprise sur
la lutte contre la pauvreté sur sa
contribution à une meilleure insertion
professionnelle sur un meilleur partage
de ces bénéfices et de série chez sur sa
contribution à la formation
professionnelle sur la prévention en
matière de santé sur la lutte contre le
greenwashing parce que tout ça peut être
aussi écrit de façon tellement détournée
que on écrit qu'on est vertu alors qu'on
n'est pas vraiment
j'ai la crainte
et je crois que cette crainte peut être
assez largement partagée entre nous que
si nous nous emparons pas des choses à
l'échelle des états et d'ailleurs il y a
là il y a une échéance européenne au
mois de juin prochain si on fait pas
trop de politique partisanes nationales
pour une fois peut être l'occasion de
s'en saisir vous avez l'occasion
en tant que entrepreneur et aux côtés de
vos salariés évidemment l'entreprise
une et une seule décrire
ce que sont les politiques ESG avant que
d'autres qui n'ont jamais mis les pieds
dans une entreprise ne les écrivent pour
vous
et c'est un peu ce message qu'on vient
vous délivrer parce que on a des idées
plein les poches il y a pas de problème
on peut faire des lois on peut faire des
règlements on peut faire des décrets on
peut écrire ce sur quoi on doit arriver
mais en réalité
plus on parle à la diversité et plus on
se rend compte que c'est cette diversité
qui doit légiférer pour elle-même en
fait voilà
alors ça se passe
en tout cas moi la mienne dans les
branches professionnelles ça se passe
oui mais bon après point relatif quand
il s'agit d'aller tordre le bras ou
faire dériver ou faire changer le bateau
de direction ça ça c'est certain il y a
un sujet alors on dérive un peu du sens
du travail il y a un sujet qui s'est en
nouvelle-aquitaine en tout cas qui a eu
lieu c'est la Région a mis en place une
éco-conditionnalité de la démarche
public et des aides publiques
ça existe et on y était favorable au
niveau du numérique on y était favorable
parce que on rêve enfin on croit enfin
on croit on espère que
on va arriver à faire en sorte que être
vertueux peut rendre quelque chose
parce qu'aujourd'hui il y a quand même
plein de situations où on peut essayer
d'être super vertueux mais le retour sur
investissement et pas génial en fait
quand vous dites que la police va passer
va vous taper de toute façon peu importe
il y a eu ça un chez Bruno Le Maire à un
moment donné il y a eu je sais qu'il y a
eu des discussions de savoir bon en gros
on pourrait regarder il y a celles qui
font le boulot on s'en occupe pas trop
et puis il y a celles qui font pas le
boulot et c'est là on va s'en occuper
qui est de manière de diviser le le
périmètre pour l'inspection l'inspection
des impôts vous voyez ce que je veux
dire d'aller taper plutôt d'un côté
plutôt de l'autre parce que ils ont
toutes les Data et il leur suffit de de
se correr quoi ça n'a pas eu lieu on
verra mais
moi je crois aux vertus de la régulation
je sais pas lequel de vous deux on a
parlé
qui en tout cas au niveau européen a
montré des choses intéressantes ça ça
initier des mouvements et c'était plus
un jeu de principe qu'on appliqué et qui
sait je pense au rgpd notamment qui
s'est qui s'est structuré et qui a eu
qui qui a maturé et puis qui a pratiqué
et qui était plus souple et qu'on a su
s'approprier et traduire donc c'est le
bon chemin c'est ça en fait c'est de
s'entendre sur des mécanismes de
régulation et des adopter et de prendre
le temps des co-construire et de jouer
un jeu collectif autour de ça mais je
veux vous rejoindre effectivement c'est
c'est pas forcément comme ça que ça va
se passer
Fabien je vais faire une contribution
parce qu'on vous écoutant je pensais
effectivement au clos des co-sociaux
conditionnalités de la région nouvelle
Aquitaine qu'on a qu'on a voté le groupe
les modérés les ont voté
bon
compliqué pour plusieurs raisons d'abord
parce que intervention avant l'Europe
on a dit écoutez l'Europe va légiférer
en faisant confiance à l'Europe
peut-être que il faudrait attendre aussi
de comment on va faire au niveau
européen parlons-en parce que comprenez
on va entraîner les chefs d'entreprise
on va les préparer à ce qui va arriver
bon c'est trouvé que c'était un peu
condescendant de la part d'une
collectivité les chefs d'entreprise ils
ont que vous l'avez vous l'avez très
bien dit ils ont ces questions
écologiques et sociales en permanence
dans le viseur ensuite on y a émis les
entreprises les associations et les
collectivités locales
ce qui est quand même pour moi pour les
collectivités locales questionnent que
les collectivités locales mérite
départements qui vont demander des aides
dorénavant à la région on se voit
traiter de la même manière ce qui paraît
un peu absurde et enfin sur les
entreprises on a assisté à un pack 2 un
peu
difficile entre
la contrainte très forte avec des seuils
très bas dans les subventions et puis
régulièrement ils ont été remontés
rabaissés bref on a fini à des seuils
qui touchent peu les subventions et
surtout pas qui touchent peu
d'entreprises en réalité il y a un seuil
minimum pour se voir appliquer ces
clauses déco sociaux conditionnalités
qui n'ont pas été concertés à part dans
quelques filières mais globalement n'a
pas été vraiment concerté sur le
territoire et si bien que au final on
arrive à quelque chose qui
peut qui peut pénaliser mais qui ne peut
pas aider à avoir une aide
éventuellement supplémentaire
parce que c'est toujours difficile de
donner des bonus c'est plus facile de
donner des malus pour les finances
publiques c'est mais c'est plus dur de
donner des bonus donc en fait on a on a
sans doute on les a voté je le répète
parce que ça allait dans le bon sens
mais je pense qu'on est parti sur
quelque chose d'un peu trop timide et
qu'on va devoir re questionner à la
lumière de ce que va faire l'Europe et
évidemment je crois aussi à la
régulation il faut que les collectivités
posent des règles mais ça s'est fait
dans quand même dans des conditions un
peu particulières et croyez moi pour
avoir participé au groupe de travail
c'était assez amusant de voir dans la
même majorité régionale et les tenants
de la ligne dure et les plus libéraux
voilà donc c'est quand même des sujets
qui traversent aussi les familles
politiques
une réaction et sinon on ouvre aux
questions de la salle moi je vais
rajouter un petit truc raconter une
petite histoire
parce que
[Musique]
je vais jeter un caillou là histoire de
faire des vagues
faut-il sauver tout le monde
on parlait de transformation numérique
les morts de la compagnie
sont remplis de boîte qui ont raté le
train et qui sont plus là et qui n'en
parlent pas
les dans les transformations il y a plus
de il y a plus de victimes entre
guillemets que de success story qui
réussissent
alors si je raconte ça c'est que alors
effectivement je suis dans un métier où
on fait de la transformation numérique
et imagina on a une spécialité sur le ce
qu'on appelle le commerce unifié donc on
prend des des groupes qui font des du
commerce qui doivent se transformer
intégrer du numérique mais il faut
intégrer ça complètement en mettant de
clients au centre enfin je raccourcis
et nos clients évidemment doivent fixer
de la transformation numérique c'est un
investissement donc il faut qu'il fasse
financer cette investissement
il y a c'était en 2023 il y a 3 ans
c'est un phénomène qui existait qui est
réel
ces entreprises ces groupes sont allés
voir leur banquier pour leur dire il
faut financer ma transformation
numérique
le banquier à regarder
la part de digitalisation existante dans
le chiffre d'affaires de ces boîtes
et s'il était inférieur à 15 % le
banquier disait vous êtes trop en retard
on ne va pas vous financer
et vous allez disparaître
parce que vous êtes déjà trop en retard
en ne vous suivra pas vous n'y arriverez
pas vous allez courir derrière les
autres qui vont plus vite que vous donc
c'est juste pour se dire ensemble que
il y a des phénomènes en cours où le tri
se fait déjà sur la vélocité l'agilité
et la faculté à suivre le mouvement donc
je crains effectivement que des choses
se passent et que effectivement de ne
pas avoir anticipé ça et de ne pas avoir
un peu préparé à arriver il va y avoir
du monde au cimetière
une petite chose je suis un petit peu
aussi hors sujet sur le sens du travail
mais j'aurais simplement dire qu'il
faudrait que la France arrête de laver
plus blanc que blanc aussi et de nous
imposer des contraintes que les autres
n'ont pas puisque on parle de l'Europe
alors je peux vraiment en parler au
niveau de l'agriculture parce que c'est
vraiment scandaleux ce qui est en train
de se passer actuellement au niveau de
l'agriculture et voilà donc si vous êtes
amené à voter des lois messieurs ou pour
l'Europe et ma petite voix dans dans le
creux de votre oreille et vous dire que
en France il faudrait qu'on arrête de
vouloir laver plus blanc que blanc parce
que c'est mettre des couches
supplémentaires de contraintes et
toujours plus loin sur la norme à un
moment donné c'est très très compliqué
moi je croise beaucoup de chefs
d'entreprise des beaucoup plus grand et
plus prestigieux que moi dans mon
quotidien et je peux cesser un sujet
récurrent voilà
et je voudrais juste ajouter une autre
petite chose c'est que alors moi je
travaille avec 52 coiffeurs
qui n'ont pas toujours belle réputation
vous savez t'es pas très bon à l'école
tu seras coiffeur ça on l'a entendu et
réentendu tellement longtemps mais tout
à l'heure vous avez un petit peu été
dans ce sens là et je voudrais dire une
chose c'est que moi je suis à des rente
du Medef depuis 15 ans alors qu'est-ce
qu'elle fait la petite coiffeuse
adhérente au MEDEF mais quand on peut le
plus on peut le moins et j'aime bien
écouter mes collègues du Medef et
j'étais encore ce matin avec notre
nouveau président du Medef Monsieur
Patrick Martin à Brive et finalement
qu'on soit coiffeur avec un CAP ou un
brevet professionnel ou qu'on soit bac +
12 dans les entreprises il y a les mêmes
problèmes
mais il est complètement
mais justement vous mettez un point il
faut absolument il faut arrêter
d'opposer les les les métiers manuels
les CAP les BEP les machins etc sur un
gamin à l'école ce qui compte c'est
qu'il a envie de faire quelque chose et
qu'il a un projet une trajectoire et que
si c'est la même avec 12 super si ça
l'amène à s'épanouir dans un métier et
coiffeur est un très beau métier c'est
tout à fait tout à fait génial aussi
c'est important c'est le c'est donner
envie de d'avancer d'avoir un projet
parce qu'après tout l'entrepreneuriat
commence là c'est l'entrepreneur à
soi-même sur le chemin qui vous amène à
la satisfaction et à vous lever le matin
pour savoir ce que vous faites en fait
merci donc moi j'avais d'abord une
première question pour toi Alexis
c'était que tu précises que ça voulait
dernière short je suis allé voir sur mon
ami Google alors le nerfore c'est oui ça
me permet de tuer quelque chose enfin
Patrick enfin vous réagirez à ce que je
veux dire
[Musique]
vous savez c'est cette faculté à
délocaliser ou à localiser dans un pays
plus ou moins lointain des gens qui vont
faire le boulot qu'on me dit qu'on
pourrait faire chez nous le Niort ça
veut dire que c'est plutôt prêt pas trop
loin donc typiquement dans
l'informatique Maroc
Roumanie
Pologne on évoquait voilà des
géographies 3 heures d'avion vous voyez
bon enfin on a 3 heures de train de
Paris je dis ça je dis rien
à ceci près que en tout cas moi c'est
c'est la compréhension de marché que
j'ai eu c'est que quand on s'est mis à
faire ça c'était moins pour aller
chercher des gens moins chers ça pouvait
être le cas que maintenant d'aller
chercher des gens qu'on a pas en fait
parce que quand on n'a pas les gens on
va dans des endroits où il y en a il se
trouve que c'est plus loin donc à la fin
ils sont moins chers mais le but du jeu
était quand même d'abord et avant tout
d'aller chercher des gens et bon il se
trouve dans le numérique depuis très
longtemps on a et mondialement il y a
une carence il y a pas assez de
bonhommes et tout le monde fait je
connais les gens qui passent leur temps
en avion et essayer de voir si de par
hasard je sais pas en ce moment au fin
fond de l'Amérique du Sud il y a pas des
développeurs en fait et on nous aurait
pas trouvé la deuxième question en fait
concerne le la part du covid donc
justement c'est cette révolution dans
dans les modalités du travail est-ce que
le fait que les gens soient restés chez
eux ça n'a pas re questionné en fait des
des choses par exemple que des parents
on pouvait considérer comme soutenable
comme acceptable et que le fait qu'on
soit resté chez soi
et à la sortie de ça en fait on voit
bien que on va on va plus accepter de
faire certaines tâches voilà il y a le
covid a quand même été un facteur
déclenchant dans cette un petit peu
cette aventure un peu désagréable que
qu'on entame avec le travail quoi le
covid est un accélérateur ça existait
déjà
le les dispositions sanitaires obligé
les gens à rester chez eux des
entreprises se sont adaptées ont trouvé
d'autres manières de faire les choses ça
s'est installé
ça c'est structuré aujourd'hui
moi dans mon domaine
[Musique]
les gens partout à deux clics et où vous
vivez dans Team c'est littéralement
et qui de par effet miroir renforce
encore plus la nécessité d'avoir
localement
un espace de vie au bureau de la vraie
vie je veux dire si vous venez au bureau
de Makina il y a presque plus d'espace
pour vivre ensemble que de bureau pour
travailler et les gens viennent pour ça
pour passer du temps ensemble moins que
pour avoir un bureau avec une clé
une chaise une table
ça ça a bougé beaucoup de choses
beaucoup de choses ont suivi de
là-dedans et après je pense que on a vu
aussi beaucoup de gens se questionner
sur leur message de la première personne
sur leur job est-ce qu'ils étaient au
bon endroit est-ce que c'est ça qu'ils
avaient envie de faire et de continuer
il y a eu de la rotation beaucoup de
gens on a vu des gens changer carrément
de voix à les faire complètement autre
chose du jour au lendemain c'est c'est
un peu passé mais quoique il y a encore
des gens qui se questionnent sur
exactement ce sur quoi il s'engage c'est
un moment de grande question géant j'ai
envie de dire de tout le monde le
travail à distance c'est on c'est
quelque chose qui effectivement a été
finalement
assez peu pratiqué avant 2020
et maintenant qu'on commence à mesurer
et 13 je pense que c'est d'abord un
problème d'activité il y a certaines
activités auxquelles ça se prête mieux
que d'autres c'est essentiellement un
problème managérial parce que manager
des gens qui sont
que vous voyez physiquement une fois par
semaine voire moins voire beaucoup moins
c'est pas du tout c'est pas du tout la
même chose que de manager des gens qui
sont tous les jours
avec vous et puis
et puis il y a des il y a vraiment une
dimension psychologique qui est pas du
tout qui est pas du tout banal donc
je pense que en l'occurrence ça c'est un
c'est une évolution qui va petit à petit
se stabiliser il y a des entreprises qui
qui continueront à l'utiliser parfois un
peu contrainte parce que c'est des
réalités de marché mais il y a quand
même énormément d'entreprises qui qui
vont chercher à
l'utiliser de façon beaucoup plus
mesurée voilà
je voulais rebondir sur une chose que
vous avez mentionné à propos de
ce qu'on moi j'ai j'ai terminé mes
études en 1990 donc effectivement les
commentaires sur
coiffeur tous ces métiers
comment dire
avant avant le bac ou bien sans études
supérieures voilà on est d'une
génération où on a entendu dénigrer tous
ces tous ces métiers là de façon alors
pour le coup totalement irresponsable
c'est clair que on est tombé
à nouveau ça fait partie de
de nos faiblesses je pense dans des
extrêmes qui sont complètement ridicules
ou voilà il faut que tout le monde est
un est un diplôme d'éducation supérieure
ce qui est absolument n'a aucun sens ça
c'est une première chose et alors en
plus maintenant avec
la transformation numérique qui est un
phénomène on en parlait tout à l'heure
qui c'est ça va pas simplement de plus
en plus vite c'est l'accélération
qu'augmente donc c'est les effets de la
transformation numérique
j'ai presque envie de dire que on
commence tout juste aller voir pourtant
ça nous paraît déjà
ça nous donne le vertige et à mon avis
on est vraiment on commence tout juste à
avoir les choses qui vont vraiment faire
exploser certaines pratiques certains
métiers et pour certains secteurs généré
des des changements énormes
ça veut dire et ça veut dire il y a des
gens qui vont perdre leur emploi il y a
des métiers qui n'existeront plus ok on
va pas rentrer sur ce qui peut se passer
pour le métier de l'assurance le métier
de la banque etc même des métiers où a
priori on a des gens plutôt qui sont
qualifiés mais il y a surtout des
métiers qualifiés pardon surtout des
métiers qualifiés surtout tout ça pour
dire que je pense que la
c'est une nécessité impérieuse de
revenir à ce à cette à cette mesure où
on est capable de montrer que ma foi il
y a on peut faire des métiers avec des
une éducation supérieure mais il y a
plein de choses extrêmement
intéressantes dans lesquelles on peut se
comment dire s'émanciper et ce et se
réaliser qui sont des métiers de service
à la personne OK et ça c'est pour la
bonne santé de l'économie c'est une
véritable nécessité que
cette évolution s'enclenche et que on
revienne à être capable de dire que ma
foi être coiffeur c'est d'abord un
service où on a une qualité de service à
gérer on a une satisfaction du client
qui est importante OK et au bout du
compte c'est tout aussi compliqué que
d'être un
programmeur qui d'ailleurs voit pas
souvent son client et n'a pas à se
confronter à à la mauvaise humeur du
client pas satisfait ok c'est tout à
fait vrai et pour le coup c'est vrai que
le télétravail par exemple c'est quelque
chose qu'un coiffeur ne peut pas
ne peut pas bénéficier donc on sait bien
à quel point en termes d'horaire et en
termes aussi d'être debout toute la
journée fin du coup vous devez sûrement
on en parlera après une question
parce qu'en fait moi qui est dirigé une
boîte de bâtiment moi c'était carreleur
donc c'est voilà si tu es pas bon tu
feras carreleur donc c'est pareil bon
à un moment je me suis arrêté de dire ce
que vous dites
une première fois il y a une quinzaine
d'années
où je disais à mes collègues du monde du
bâtiment arrêtez de dire qu'il faut
revaloriser les métiers du bâtiment ce
que vous reconnaissez vous-même que
c'est des métiers dévalorisés
donc faut faire très attention en termes
de communication et de messages qui
passent
et une deuxième fois je dis maintenant
il faut qu'on faut qu'on change
complètement de logiciel
c'est quand on a vu exploser les
contrats d'apprentissage grâce aux
entreprises qui ont repris leur
responsabilité grâce aux réformes hôtels
grâce aux accompagnements financiers et
grâce à une prise de conscience c'est à
dire que moi aujourd'hui quand on parle
à nos enfants en fait
à 18 20 22 ans ils ont aucun problème à
être coiffeur boulanger maçon machin ils
ont intégré tout ça se fait très vite
avec des maquettes numériques de toute
façon ils vivent avec leur smartphone
donc pour eux c'est même pas moderne en
fait c'est juste normal donc voilà
c'est une note optimiste et mais je sais
que comme chef d'entreprise on a le
réflexe de revenir systématiquement
là-dessus parce qu'en fait on est dans
une crise du recrutement mais général de
tous les métiers et c'est pas parce que
certains métiers sont dévalorisés en
fait je pense que au contraire le seul
sujet qui vaudra désormais c'est que les
métiers qui peuvent pas être
télétravaillés doivent redéfinir les
grilles de salaire
ce qu'on a appelé les travailleurs de
première ligne cela doit être beaucoup
beaucoup mieux payés
et ça c'est un sujet pour les
collectivités locales c'est compliqué de
gérer les budgets mais nos cadres c'est
dans les collectivités qui de toute
façon eux peuvent pas télétrailler parce
que ils sont dans le service il y a
quand on est en service à la personne
que ce soit sur les enfants sur les
personnes âgées sur le la sur le
domicile en fait parce que on réglera
votre pas tous les problèmes avec les
EHPAD quand on est sur des métiers non
télétravables c'est-à-dire des métiers
traditionnels qui sont des métiers de
service de production de fabrication ou
maintenant effectivement le les jeunes
n'ont pas de souci à aller en sachant
parce que ils l'ont intégré désormais
qu'ils auront quatre ou cinq métiers
différents dans leur vie donc ça leur
pose zéro souci
il y a encore plein d'angle morts dans
tout ça mais en fait à un moment
le sujet qui se posera c'est pour ça que
moi j'étais assez content qu'il
ressortent de la première rencontre qui
a eu lieu entre tous les chefs de parti
politique à la fin on irait sur une
conférence sociale et salariale
faut peut-être redéfinir le prix d'une
prestation faut pas rediscuter que le
prix de la consultation médicale
il faut peut-être rediscuter le prix du
mètre carré de carrelage de la Coupe
chez le coiffeur et du prix qu'on paye
un éboueur et de tondre le gazon des
espaces verts de la ville de Limoges
et ça c'est un joli sujet de société bon
juste faire une petite remarque je suis
entièrement d'accord avec ce que disait
madame puisque moi je fais partie d'une
association qui intervient à la Mission
Locale de Brive ainsi qu'à les rips et
nous intervenons aussi pour aider les
élèves dans les lycées techniques au
niveau BTS et à trouver des stages
intéressants à trouver des entreprises
qui peut les qui peuvent les accueillir
et la remarque que je vais faire à ce
sujet c'est que c'est très difficile
dans la mesure où à 20-22 ans les gens
qui sont en BTS ou en DUT ils ne savent
pas ce qu'ils veulent faire et dans en
15 ans d'expérience dans ce domaine là
j'en ai trouvé elle est moins d'une
dizaine qui avait véritablement un
objectif de comment de pas de carrière
parce que ils savent qu'ils vont changer
mais un objectif de travail à court
terme relativement court terme et un
exemple le plus le plus flagrant que
j'ai pu avoir c'est un exemple où c'est
l'État qui a défini un petit peu
notamment des jeunes filles qui venaient
de Mayotte pour faire des études dans un
lycée agricole mais parce que à Mayotte
on fait très peu d'agriculture et elle
n'avait en tête que de vouloir faire de
l'assistance maternelle service à la
personne pour les enfants et quand ils
ont terminé leurs études de BTS pas très
loin d'ici elles sont allées faire garde
d'enfants et s'occuper d'enfants du côté
de Cholet c'est bien alors
qu'est-ce qui m'a amené à faire ce genre
d'action bon c'est parce que j'ai
lorsque j'ai pris ma retraite il y a
maintenant presque une vingtaine
d'années
j'ai travaillé longtemps très longtemps
à l'étranger j'ai travaillé j'ai fait le
compte dans 43 pays différents alors de
temps en temps de façon très courte une
journée et puis de façon aussi beaucoup
plus longue le pays où je suis resté le
plus longtemps c'était 7 ans et bon
c'était même assez loin et là j'ai vu
quand même des systèmes très différents
et des systèmes très variés et ce qui me
semble actuellement pour permettre aux
enfants aux ados de faire un choix c'est
de leur donner des billes de leur dire
un petit peu
quels sont les avantages là quels sont
les salaires aussi parce que c'est
intéressant aussi parce qu'il travaille
pour gagner leur vie et ça
ils ont été surpris de savoir qu'un
plombier souvent gagné beaucoup plus que
le patron de la boîte d'à côté
et il y avait un manque de plombier
essayez de faire réparer une comment une
machine à laver que vous avez acheté
chez Darty c'est impossible vous la
retrouvez pas ou en bout ou un morceau
donc il y a comment déjà tout à l'heure
une immense
zone pas grise jouer justement avec des
débouchés possibles et avec la
possibilité de rendre le produit durable
dont on parle maintenant plutôt que de
l'Oger et d'en acheter un autre
voilà alors maintenant je remodis sur un
autre sujet qui est la comment la
motivation des gens dans les entreprises
on a beaucoup parlé de télétravail et
moi j'ai travaillé dans deux grandes
sociétés françaises disons de taille
internationale bon je vous dirais par
lesquels mais elles sont leaders sur
leur marché
elles sont pas dans l'informatique
excusez-moi et comment on avait dans une
des filiales
j'avais la direction disons d'un secteur
on avait mis au point
non seulement la participation qui est
obligatoire mais l'intéressement
collectif est l'intéressement individuel
des gens
au niveau de la sécurité c'est les gens
de l'atelier qui étaient responsables de
faire respecter les consignes de
sécurité moralité on est resté 12 ans
sans accident du travail
et ça ça a été vrai aussi pour les
acides à créditation au niveau de la
qualité ils ont 9001 etc etc chaque fois
que l'accréditation était renouvelée
chacun avait une prime bon et ça c'était
débattu tous les ans au cours d'une
journée complète où tous les employés
tous étaient invités il y a quelques
délégués syndicaux qui ne venaient pas
bon ça faisait 5 personnes sur deux sens
c'était pas grave voilà la commande la
l'exemple que je voulais vous citer
je poursuis dans la salle je vais monter
les marches qui
bonsoir Hugues de la salle donc moi je
suis commerçant dans le Nord
Haute-Vienne je suis relativement
surpris d'entendre finalement ce débat
déjà parce que là on entend parler de
transformation numérique c'est pas de la
transformation numérique que vous faites
c'est de la transformation sociétale par
le numérique on a besoin du numérique ça
a apporté énormément de confort c'est
certain mais la société elle est
constituée d'individus avant tout et la
part d'humanité de chaque individu est
en train de disparaître petit à petit à
cause du numérique le numérique est en
train d'envahir en fait on a une perte
de contrôle de nos vies l'administration
de plus en plus utilise le numérique les
sociétés entre elles les employés dans
les sociétés communiques à travers le
numérique ne se déplace quasiment plus
pour aller discuter et là on s'étonne
après qu'on ait une perte de sens du
travail mais le travail c'est aussi en
tout cas le sens du travail c'est
l'empathie avec avec l'autre avec son
prochain effectivement chez le coiffeur
c'est toujours très intéressant
d'entendre les discussions qu'il y a
dans ce salon entre la coiffeuse ou le
coiffeur et sa cliente ou son client
mais c'est vrai dans d'autres dans
d'autres professions le numérique petit
à petit en fait on n'a pas su mettre le
curseur au bon endroit et en train de
tuer cette relation directe ce besoin
que nous avons d'être en contact de se
toucher on se rend pas compte à quel
point en fait il y a un décalage et un
éloignement du de l'outil numérique de
la génération du dessus nos parents mais
également de la génération du dessous
vous fréquentez effectivement une
certaine élite des jeunes qui
poursuivent leurs études très bien moi
je connais et je crois énormément de
jeunes qui aujourd'hui sont très à
l'aise avec un ordinateur un smartphone
mais ils sont très à l'aise pour jouer
pour jouer demandez-leur de faire des
de travailler avec un ordinateur
demander l'heure de faire du tout toutes
les démarches administratives avec un
ordinateur ils sont perdus ils vont
travailler et ils vont taper à la porte
de France maison française
de ce côté-là nous avons un problème un
véritable problème sociétal l'Europe
nous pousse toujours plus mais j'ai à la
mondialisation générale vers cet outil
informatique qui a fait votre Votre
Grandeur et votre richesse et nous en
profitons tous parce que ça fait évoluer
notre société mais je pense qu'il est
temps aujourd'hui de se reposer la vraie
question et quel est le but final de la
numérisation à outrance de notre société
est-ce que c'est tout simplement la
croissance
et on doit en permanence auto-alimenter
le système parce qu'on ne peut plus
faire sans la croissance je suis pas
convaincu que la décroissance soit une
solution mais est-ce qu'on peut pas
tourner aujourd'hui notre économie vers
autre chose que le numérique qui est en
train de perdre tout ça nous paiement la
relation entre les individus on crée un
monde virtuel dans lequel nous sommes
complètement piégés on peut pas se
plaire au travail quand même dans la vie
privée nous sommes complètement engoncé
on a l'impression d'avoir perdu le
contrôle d'être soumis à une une
pression de des gafam mais également de
l'administration toujours à travers cet
outil numérique donc moi la question est
vraiment ouverte et je pense que
aujourd'hui on voit des extrêmes de part
et d'autre à gauche très marqué où il
souhaite la décroissance complète
sûrement pas la solution mais à droite
également parce que les uns et les
autres se rejettent et au centre on voit
toujours les mêmes qui nous disent non
mais avec le numérique vous allez pas le
choix vous allez mourir si vous ne
suivez pas alors rassurez-vous vous
allez mourir vous aussi moi
on nous en sommes convaincus c'est une
réalité et une entreprise meurt
également une entreprise c'est une
personne morale qui à un moment ou un
autre toute façon va descendre il y a
des effets de mode le l'effet de mode du
numérique à outrance je pense est passé
et on va prendre un effet boomerang
retour boomerang extraordinaire
merci
à vous donc une réponse puis après les
questions le numérique c'est un outil
et je n'apprends rien c'est de la
philosophie se servir des outils nous
transforme
c'est un fait il y a pas de plan par
contre effectivement le numérique a
changé beaucoup de choses
à changer les gens à changer des tonnes
de trucs
et c'est vrai on le disait dans la
transformation numérique l'erreur c'est
de considérer ça au niveau des outils et
il y a beaucoup trop de je vous dans
votre sens il y a beaucoup trop de
d'appropriation du numérique projet
numérique il ne cherche que la
productivité l'effet d'échelle et ce
genre de choses la ce qui est très
important c'est de remettre
l'utilisateur au milieu l'individu au
milieu et de regarder ce que ça fabrique
alors c'est fait
on va pas revenir en arrière c'est de la
machine à remonter le temps ça n'existe
pas donc ça se regarde c'est
complètement juste que les jeunes
aujourd'hui s'en servent
sont différents de nous
effectivement il faut faire une grande
différence entre être à l'aise avec un
smartphone numérique savoir comment ça
marche savoir faire quelque chose avec
autre chose c'est complètement différent
c'est aussi vrai que alors ça a des
effets de bord moi pour tout vous dire
j'étais persuadé il y a quelques années
que en volume dans le numérique on
allait prendre une loi sanitaire une loi
sanitaire notamment vous le savez tous
uniquement Facebook c'est un dealer ils
vont de la dopamine c'est le cœur de son
business qu'on fait un like ça Fabrice à
un shoot de dopamine dans votre tête
c'est très connu ça c'est un enjeu de
régulation moi j'étais persuadé qu'on
prendrait une loi sanitaire tant d'écran
et toutes ces sortes de choses et ça n'a
pas eu lieu c'est très étonnant
d'ailleurs je permets de le dire c'est
très étonnant par l'écho conditionnalité
et sociaux conditionnalité mais il y
aurait pu avoir ça enfin vous savez que
les chinois ils ont demandé aux
opérateurs de couper le jeu vidéo au
bout d'un certain temps d'utilisation ça
existe alors c'est pas possible dans nos
sociétés mais c'est un vrai sujet je
suis d'accord avec vous mais c'est un
sujet de régulation voilà après ça a
changé ça nous a changé et ça a changé
la société et comme tous les outils ça
fabrique du bien et ça fabrique du moins
bien
et ça il peut c'est l'usage comme on
fait et il y a pas de plan il y a pas de
plan par contre ce qui est complètement
vrai et ça on est d'accord c'est que
alors de la croissance
en tout cas ça met l'économie en
mouvement ça on peut pas dire le
contraire voilà ça met l'économie en
mouvement et aujourd'hui c'est peut-être
difficile d'en sortir voilà mais c'est
on est dedans quoi donc après on peut
tous agir collectivement effectivement
pour amener peut-être plus de régulation
et autres mais encore une fois vous il
n'y a pas de bouton Retour arrière ça
c'est une certitude mais c'est vrai qu'à
un moment donné des gens ont dit on va
changer le monde et le monde a changé
c'est totalement exact après on est tous
connectés on est on est aussi tous les
uns à un clic les uns des autres il y a
une conscience peut-être un peu plus
grande de l'humanité en elle-même à
travers tout ça il y a un peu plus
dialogue la connaissance est partagée
enfin il y a plein de choses positives
mais il y a c'est pas tout blanc ou tout
noir il y a plein de gris et
effectivement il y a il y a un sujet par
contre que je retiens et vous avez
raison là-dessus c'est que des fois ça
va un peu trop loin et on oublie des de
population qui sont à l'écart de tout ça
il y a des enjeux alors on ne fait que
parler en ce moment d'inclusion et qu'il
faut inclure etc et oui aujourd'hui
c'est moi-même alors je suis le monsieur
du numérique ce soir mais c'est pas
normal qui est pas des lieux ouverts ou
des vrais gens vont se déplacer en vrai
parce que ils peuvent pas faire
autrement parce que l'écran et tout ça
c'est pas possible voilà et c'est très
important et c'est un enjeu de service
public de pouvoir raccrocher une part de
population qui est complètement écartée
de tout ça de la même façon que les lois
sur le handicap ne sont pas appliquées
au niveau des services numériques pour
permettre une vraie prise en compte de
handicap y compris dans l'usage mais
après il y a des
il y a des il y a la recherche il y a
des gens qui travaillent là-dessus sur
des usages que ça fabrique etc etc quand
on parle des jeunes par exemple pour
donner un truc c'est assez intéressant
de voir comment certains enseignants
utilisent les habilités que les conjux
vidéos confèrent à des gamins
par exemple le jeu vidéo vous les les
jeunes ont de plus fortes habilités à
travailler ensemble et à faire des
projets ensemble et à coopérer ce qu'ils
ont appris notamment en jouant dans les
jeux parce qu'il y a des jeux où vous
gagnez parce que vous êtes en équipe et
que vous jouez des rôles des uns et des
autres en fait il faut trier tout ça il
faut regarder ce qui est moins bien
c'est c'est très compliqué votre
question et le sens mais il y a sans
doute un enjeu de régulation et il y a
aussi une grosse prise de conscience à
amener à tout le monde et à tous les
individus à comment dire objectiver
leurs pratiques à regarder ce qu'ils
font il y a des addictions il y a toutes
sortes de phénomènes etc petit à petit
c'est pris en compte donc ça avance
peut-être pas assez vite mais ça avance
mais ne croyez pas qu'il y a pas de
conscience de tout ça c'est c'est un
vrai sujet je le redis on était on est
dans le numérique on était persuadés je
vous dis il y a 5 ans qu'on allait qu'on
allait se prendre une loi sanitaire
voilà ça peut être mieux mais on s'y
préparé c'est c'était pour dire à quel
point je veux juste je pense que en tous
les cas
[Musique]
les discussions qu'on a essayé de
mettre en place
ne partent pas du de l'hypothèse on n'a
pas le choix c'est comme ça c'est tout
c'est pas
c'est quand même une réalité ok c'est
une réalité il y a au moins quelques
aspects positifs de la de
l'évolution de ces outils numériques
et en revanche je pense quand même que
il y a aussi une prise de conscience
des pouvoirs publics que ce soit au
niveau français ou bien que ce soit au
niveau européen
c'est
dans les dans les grands grands
ensembles européens l'Union européenne
est quand même le premier à avoir essayé
définir tous les toutes les toutes les
règles qui ont été
définies cette année aussi bien sur les
problèmes de de propriété des données
que de protection des utilisateurs etc
il faut quand même savoir que l'Europe
est un cas unique qui essaye
dans un consensus qui est pas simple à
obtenir à 27 pays c'est mais il y a
quand même des initiatives très fortes
et je pense que
moi personnellement je suis pas aussi
pessimiste je pense que
voilà peut-être qu'elle arrive pas
suffisamment vite cette prise de
conscience mais en tous les cas elle est
là et
bon ensuite il faut trouver un équilibre
mais en tous les cas dans notre dans le
cas de la réflexion qu'on a mis en place
moi personnellement je suis convaincu
que
il y a un véritable enjeu à ce que
l'évolution de cet outil qui a quelque
chose d'un petit peu inexorable parce
que en tous les cas qu'on apporte des
vraies réponses humanistes pour
accompagner
un maximum les gens qui travaillent dans
dans l'entreprise ça je suis absolument
convaincu que mais ça se fera pas là
pour le coup ça ne se fera pas de façon
centralisée il n'y a pas de recette
miracle qui marque qui marche pour les 4
millions d'entreprises par exemple pour
le marché français il va falloir arriver
à ce que une fois encore tout ça se
passe de façon très décentralisée au
niveau des entreprises mais il y a pas
doute il faut accompagner les gens qui
qui sont directement impactés par
l'apparition ou le développement de
certains outils ça c'est je suis
entièrement d'accord avec vous
merci on va prendre
vous allez devant vous le premier mec
qui a fait une loi face au gafam pour
qu'ils les obliger à payer les articles
de presse qui utilisent pour profiter
les gens
et je pense qu'il faut faire une
différence entre le numérique et les
réseaux sociaux
c'est ces deux choses extrêmement
différentes et autant le numérique moi
je crois que a bien des égards on est
dans parfois en phase de dénumérisation
parce que les services publics
commencent en fait à mettre à
disposition c'est typiquement les
maisons françaises voilà de des
personnes qui vont aller faire du
service public sont forcément qui soit
numérisés et ça c'est un effet de
régulation que vous venez de décrire et
qui va avoir lieu mais naturellement
parce que le public le demande en
revanche les réseaux sociaux présentent
un véritable danger
au sens où chacun accepte
de vendre ce qu'il est pour pouvoir être
profilé pour qu'ensuite les réseaux
sociaux revendre les profils à des
entreprises comme on vendrait des
publicités
ça dans le cadre juridique européen dans
le cadre juridique français
c'est interdit sauf que l'interdiction
n'est pas appliquée
et donc il y a deux directives
européennes qui viennent de sortir sur
le sujet les DS
voilà et qu'on va transposer en droit
français on va essayer de pas sur
transposer comme d'habitude mais on va
transposer quand même pour protéger les
données personnelles alors il y a
énormément d'éducation à faire chez tout
le monde parce que quand vous êtes en
train d'utiliser votre smartphone et que
vous passez une commande et puis que
c'est urgent parce que c'est un billet
de train c'est pour tout à l'heure vous
êtes tendance à cliquer sur tous les
boutons pour accepter tous les cookies
c'est comme si vous envoyez votre photo
de vous nu
et vous le faites de bon cœur pour avoir
le billet SNCF et vous avez oublié que
vous venez du jour comme ça
immédiatement
délibérément volontairement de dire tout
ce que vous êtes
mais c'est là que la régulation doit
rentrer en ligne de compte c'est à dire
c'est
l'interdiction d'utilisation de Facebook
la première mesure sanitaire qui a fait
y avoir lieu aux États-Unis
c'était la mesure de démantèlement de
Facebook dans le cadre des lois
antitrust je pense
qu'on avance vers ça qu'on va aller vers
ça c'est je vous disais tout à l'heure
que j'avais été le premier à légiférer
en fait pour que les réseaux sociaux et
Google payent à la presse et en
particulier à la presse quotidienne
régionale les articles qui pompent
gratuitement et qu'ensuite ils revendent
ce qui est quand même
c'est absurde parce que le profilage
parce que vous lisez l'équipe et vous
lisez le monde donc en fait on va vous
envoyer forcément des produits qui
intéressent le lecteur de l'équipe et du
monde donc en fait on vous vend deux
fois moi je me suis retrouvé dans mon
bureau avec un vice-président de d'une
de ces très grandes entreprises qui est
venue menacer directement quoi
parce que ils sont sans foi ni loi
et ce que ce à quoi j'ai été en train de
m'attaquer c'était 3 milliards de
revenus publicitaires directs 3
milliards
ils ont fini par passer un deal avec les
entreprises de presse à hauteur de 130
millions
donc en effet il y a besoin de régler
et vous vous trouvez actuellement et
d'ailleurs c'est ce que fait Jean-Noël
Barrault au niveau du numérique vous
avez vu de temps en temps il est assez
courageux enfin il vient de suspendre la
commercialisation de l'iPhone 12 je
pense que le patron d'Apple se dit mais
qui est ce mec c'est c'est il y a un
ministre du numérique en France qui
vient de m'interdire de mettre à
disposition un iPhone sur le marché mais
qu'est-ce que c'est que ça alors que moi
je suis maître du monde
là on va être effectivement obligé de
obliger de reprendre la main et
quelque chose me dit que finalement
cette Assemblée nationale assez
disparate
peut se retrouver sur deux ou trois
sujets dont celui là
pour arriver à protéger les données
personnelles parce qu'il y a un danger
économique
il y a un danger sociétal et il y a un
danger sans m'étendre dessus de
démocratique
parce qu'en fait il vous en fait avec
ces algorithmes les réseaux sociaux vous
enferme à l'intérieur de vos propres
convictions on ne fréquentant plus que
des gens que vous connaissez déjà et qui
pensent comme vous et qui ne vous envoie
que des informations même si elles sont
fausses qui vous plaisent parce que vous
les avez déjà consultés
à ce jeu là la démocratie finale
donc je suis moins pessimiste que vous
parce que je sais parfois que l'étape
avoir une puissance régulatrice gênante
mais parfois ça le vatrice
oui donc merci de votre venue dans notre
territoire où il y a beaucoup d'emplois
très précaires et beaucoup de souffrance
au travail moi je le vois tous les jours
dans mes mandats syndicaux je militant
syndical et c'est des choses aussi qu'on
débat au modem 97 avec très souvent
donc moi ce que je rencontre c'est
vraiment des gens qui sont investis dans
leur travail qui aiment leur travail sur
les Français ils attachent beaucoup
d'importants sur leur travail mais qui
sont souvent empêchés de faire leur
travail et qui sont pas reconnus ni
socialement
ni au niveau de leur salaire et tout ça
le manque de reconnaissance sociale
salariale le manque de carrière
professionnelle ascendante le manque de
l'attitude dans son travail
le manque
le fait qu'on ne reconnaît pas
l'expertise des gens tout ça
c'est pas l'état qu'il empêche parce que
vous avez été assez sévère sur l'état
empêche des tas de choses nous ce qu'on
voit dans l'entreprise c'est pas que les
temps empêchent de faire c'est que les
entreprises elles négocient pas
il y a pas beaucoup de dialogues
sociales il y a pas beaucoup d'avancées
il y a des minima qui sont inférieurs au
SMIC personnel interdit une entreprise à
payer les gens un peu au-dessus du SMIC
il y a des gens qui restent 7 ans 8 ans
10 ans au SMIC c'est pas l'état qu'il
oblige ça voyez donc il y a aussi une
responsabilité sociétale mais aussi des
entreprises des entrepreneurs de dire
moi comment je fais pour parce que là on
n'est pas enfin là on a parlé des
métiers high-tech là mais moi je vois
des métiers dans l'industrie dans le
médico-social dans la santé dans les
dans les dans le service public aussi
parce qu'il est pas il est loin d'être
parfait et là il y a un manque de et un
manque de oui de reconnaissance de
l'implication des gens dans leur travail
parce que c'est une implication qui est
forte et c'est vrai vous avez raison les
gens ils sont fiers de leur travail mais
faut-il encore qu'on le reconnaisse le
pouvoir d'agir sur leur travail et le
pouvoir de négocier des choses et il y a
des syndicats le mieux en premier et
d'autres on est prêt à faire ça mais il
faut aussi qu'en face il y ait des chefs
d'entreprise qui acceptent qui soit pas
toujours à 9 salariés pour pas avoir le
délégué du personnel à 49 salariés pour
pas avoir le CSE et qui négocient des
choses et après il faut voir ce que
c'est le parcours syndical d'entreprise
la reconnaissance tout ça c'est
important donc je pense qu'en France
c'est vrai qu'il y a une situation il y
a des études internationales qui
montrent qu'il y a même qui est très mal
placé sur les conditions de travail sur
la qualité sur le contenu du travail et
ça il faut qu'on bouge sinon enfin qui a
même la France elle est pas exemplaire
là-dessus et je crois que c'est pas que
on ferait fausse route en disant que
c'est l'État qui est interdit tout ce
n'est pas vrai l'État peut être que
parfois il est interventionniste on l'a
vu sur la sur la conférence sociale ou
monsieur Macron en pleine nuit décide
qu'on va augmenter les bas salaires
et les partenaires sociaux alors ils
décident de quoi donc c'est sûr que là
on n'a pas une on n'a pas un rôle qui
qui est celui qu'on devrait avoir mais
après dans l'entreprise enfin moi je
suis sûr qu'en Haute-Vienne ou en Creuse
en Corrèze ailleurs il y a des
entreprises sur lequel on pourrait agir
des représentants du personnel et des
chefs d'entreprise pour faire progresser
les choses donc là je sais pas ce que
vous pensez un peu de ce que nous de ce
que moi je vis depuis tant d'années je
fais du syndicalisme comme un peu une
panne du dialogue social du dialogue
professionnel en entreprise pourquoi ça
marche pas et pourquoi ça marche en
Allemagne en au Pays-Bas au Danemark
dans l'état de pays
je vais vous répondre pourquoi mais je
veux rappeler une chose c'est que pour
la première fois
et nous qui avons militer depuis des
années pour le tous les outils de
partage de la valeur de participation
d'intéressement de conférence salariale
de réouverture des dialogues sociaux
pour la première fois les syndicats en
France ont signé un ailing l'année
dernière la corde nationale
interprofessionnelle c'est une avancée
majeure je
n'espérais pas il y a encore un an de ça
que ça puisse arriver c'est le cas
et c'est là que moi maintenant que je
peluche je peux le dire c'est j'en veux
un peu même si j'ai beaucoup travaillé
avec eux et que je connais super bien
Patrick Martin j'en veux un peu à ceux
qui ont signé cette aini de pas avoir
enclenché ensuite la mise en œuvre enfin
on a demandé au gouvernement et au
parlementaire d'inscrire dans la loi il
y en avait absolument pas besoin quand
il y a un accord national
interprofessionnel il y a pas besoin
d'inscrire dans la loi au contraire on
va encore nous dire qu'est-ce que vous
ne nous emmerder à mettre dans la loi un
truc sur lesquels on s'est mis d'accord
tout syndicat confondu patronat et
syndicat et je pense que aujourd'hui il
y a plus qu'à s'en saisir il y a plus
qu'à ramasser le truc et il doit y avoir
un mouvement
du monde syndical quel qu'il soit pour y
aller
aujourd'hui l'outil existe on sait que
il y a beaucoup de travailleurs qui sont
mal payés non seulement c'est l'occasion
de renégocier un certain nombre de
minima alors c'est dingue mais on va
être obligé de légiférer sur les 13
branches qui sont encore inférieures au
SMIC on va le faire ça fait un an qu'on
en parle et personne s'y colle donc on
va effectivement faire intervenir l'état
on est quand même dans un monde de fou
il y a des branches dans lesquelles il y
a des discussions entre représentants
syndicaux et représentants
professionnels qui choisissent de pas
appliquer la loi
c'est un monde de fou donc ça on va le
faire voilà mais après la Henni c'est
s'il y a une chose à dire je suis pas le
syndicat dans lequel vous êtes bien
c'est mais leur représentant des parc
mental leur présentant régional de
Marylise Léon
et quel jeudi dernier avec le président
de la République en CNR à un moment faut
juste taper sur la table on a signé il y
a 6 mois on fait quoi dans chaque
entreprise et c'est à ça que va servir
la conférence sociale et salariale c'est
à déclencher et c'est je trouve assez
bizarre en fait qu'on est passé en
accord national et que maintenant
au détourne le regard et on attend que
quelqu'un nous dise de nous y mettre
enfin et c'est absolument l'occasion sur
la question du pourquoi moi j'ai le
sentiment que j'ai reçu les syndicats
nationaux faisaient un peu plus de
syndicalisme un peu moins de politique
ça serait bien voilà et s'il est parti
politique essayez pas d'être trop leur
correspondant ça sera encore mieux voilà
c'est le vrai dialogue social il se fait
dans l'entreprise et de temps en temps
c'est pas interdit d'engueuler et les
syndicalistes
qui pensent à faire leur truc et
d’engueuler les représentants pas trop
d'eau de pas y aller moi quand je vois
je rencontre des représentants du BDF
dans mon département lui vous en êtes où
là sur l'application de la ligne vous
allez donner des outils à vos à vos
adhérents pour que ils puissent ouvrir
des discussions un peu partout coûte
rien en plus mettre en place un accord
d'intéressement type on demande ça un
stagiaire il tombe le truc en trois
heures et il envoie à tous les adhérents
du Medef
et ensuite on fait une réunion avec les
salariés qui sont trois qui sont 5 qui
sont neuf qui sont 14 l'affaire est
faite
de ma gueule ils ont signé ensemble
maintenant donc ce que je disais est
vrai il y a plus qu'à faire
je crains qu'on soit obligé de passer
par la Conférence sociale et salariale
pour dire et bah l'accord que vous avez
trouvé ensemble vous savez quoi
maintenant vous allez l'appliquer
alors moi je voulais parler revenir au
sens salaire et revenu
on dit toujours que la société française
et patriarcale moi je trouve qu'elle est
très matriarcale et que les jeunes la
vivent un peu comme traumaternante
presque c'est à dire que ce qui vous ce
qu'ils veulent c'est un salaire plutôt
qu'un revenu ils vivent de plus en plus
mal le chèque énergie le chèque la PL le
chèque qu'est-ce qu'on a on a eu le
carburant le la prime Macron
il y a une différence entre le revenu et
le salaire le salaire c'est sa valeur
individuelle les revenus les chèques
sont assez mal vécus parce que
finalement c'est même la caution qu'on a
qu'on ne gagne pas assez d'argent pour
avoir droit à ses chèques
il y a vraiment un vrai problème je
pense alors effectivement il y a des
gens avec les prestations sociales etc
ils arrivent facilement à 18
mais ils ont pas l'impression que leur
valeur c'est 1800 euros parce que leur
valeur c'est la dernière ligne du
salaire c'est le net à payer et est-ce
que ça va se corriger un jour
alors là c'est beaucoup de choses à
revoir dans toutes les sociétés mais
c'est quelque chose qui moi je me rends
compte j'ai un fils de 21 ans et il a
plein de copains de copines etc mais ils
ne voient pas les aides complémentaires
comme du revenu enfin comme du salaire
comme du cash il parle beaucoup de cash
voilà
moi je vais donner ma petite réponse à
moi en tant que chef d'entreprise
tu avances Muriel que il le vivent mal
de recevoir ses chèques mais moi en tant
que chef d'entreprise aussi parce que je
trouve que c'est du bricolage et que
c'est pas digne d'un pays comme la
France qu'on fasse du bricolage comme ça
il faudrait qu'il y a une vraie qu'on se
positionne réellement sur les revenus du
travail les revenus sociaux même si ils
doivent exister parce que moi je suis
chef d'entreprise d'accord je crée de la
richesse mais je ne veux pas non plus
que mon pays laisse sur le carreau des
gens qui ne peuvent pas travailler ou
des gens et je pense que de faire du
social c'est tout à fait normal mais
effectivement il faudrait qu'il y ait un
écart plus important entre les revenus
du travail et les revenus qu'on donne
aux gens qui ne peuvent pas travailler
parce que il y a cette confusion dont tu
parles très bien et qui existe
réellement moi j'en parle régulièrement
avec mes collaborateurs parce que ils
comprennent pas et moi non plus je
comprends pas voilà et je ne rêve que
d'une chose c'est qu'on puisse faire
évoluer ça après j'aimerais aussi qu'on
évoluer les salaires alors moi j'aime
pas tellement ce mot là mais
effectivement les bas salaires mais ça
passe aussi par un accompagnement de
l'entreprise parce que mes salariés en
coiffure moi j'en ai aucun qui est au
SMIC parce que moi le matin quand je me
lève il y en a qui pensent à être
président quand il se rase moi quand je
me lave les dents je vais pouvoir me
regarder et me dire je n'ai pas des
salariés au SMIC malheureusement ils
sont pas tous payés énormément au-delà
du SMIC parce que en coiffure il
faudrait que mes clientes acceptent de
payer beaucoup plus cher pour que je
puisse payer plus mes coiffeurs alors ça
c'est des thématiques que je connais par
cœur parce que je voudrais pouvoir les
les augmenter plus mais malheureusement
mon entreprise elle n'a pas les
capacités et à un moment il y a un
arbitrage qui se fait il y a un cadre il
faut pas que je puisse je sorte du cadre
sinon je mets en difficulté mon
entreprise et ça ça arrive pour beaucoup
de monde beaucoup d'entreprises et en
même temps il faut pouvoir
satisfaire les besoins des
collaborateurs qui me disent mais moi je
suis toute seule parce que les femmes
qui sont seules et on n'a pas du tout
parlé ce soir mais c'était pas le sujet
non plus de la soirée mais on pourrait
parler de sujet là très longtemps les
femmes qui sont seules et qui assument
seul des enfants pour elle
un salaire juste un peu au dessus du
SMIC c'est très très compliqué et mais
il faudrait aussi que les entreprises
soient accompagnées soit un petit peu
aider par rapport à ce seuil là pour que
on puisse payer un peu plus les
collaborateurs mais qui est peut-être
moins de charge parce que les les
entreprises comme les miennes on est
croulé sous les charges je fais partie
des salons de coiffure il y a 7 % des
salons de coiffure qui donne des tickets
restaurants
voilà en France il y a que 7% des salons
de coiffure qui donne des tickets
restaurants c'est peut-être aussi pour
ça que je fidélise mes collaborateurs
par mes tickets restaurants c'est un
effort que je fais mais c'est un effort
que je pense être normal et mérité après
en ce qui concerne les primes chez moi
aussi il y a des primes je j'essaye dans
mon quotidien et ça s'appelle de
l'agilité parce que souvent je suis à la
limite de dire là ma ma salariale je
vais plus pouvoir c'est pas possible
voilà et ça c'est la difficulté des
chefs d'entreprise comme moi qui parfois
et ça m'est arrivé moi aussi alors il y
a longtemps maintenant mais parfois de
pas me payer moi et c'est pas je sais
pas un cas il y a des tas d'entreprises
ou quand le patron il a payé ses
salariés ses charges son loyer et ben il
a plus rien pour se payer lui parce que
je vous entends monsieur parler des
syndicats moi j'ai rien contre les
syndicats au contraire je trouve que
c'est très bien mais les deux
aussi bien pour les salariés que pour
les patrons parce qu'il y a aussi des
patrons qui ont besoin d'être défendu
aussi patron qui ne savent pas certaines
lois qui savent pas faire il y a des
choses qui savent pas faire
mais je pense qu'à un moment donné il
faut aussi arrêter de taper sur
l'ambulance et que remettre l'entreprise
au cœur du village ça pourrait aussi
être bien parce que c'est quand même pas
l'entreprise qu'il y a aussi des
salariés et pas interdit de rêver mais
j'aimerais aussi qu'on éduque les jeunes
dès le plus jeune âge a rencontré des
entreprises et à rencontrer des chefs
d'entreprises aux États-Unis les jeunes
ils rêvent tous de monter un business en
France monter un business c'est presque
un gros mot de vouloir gagner de
l'argent c'est un gros mot et ça c'est
assez déstabilisant et assez
moi ça m'interroge voilà ça a progressé
oui alors moi ça va être très bref parce
que je voulais juste te dire ce que
Samia disait on parle là actuellement
d'entreprise qui sont florissantes et
qui ont de très bons très bonnes
recettes mais c'est vrai augmenter les
salariés je pense que tous les patrons
voudraient augmenter mais même quand
tout va bien il se disent attends
aujourd'hui ça va bien mais
l'incertitude du futur et là est
toujours présent donc on se dit si
aujourd'hui je m'engage fait une
augmentation qui est pérenne je ne parle
pas des primes puisque les prix mon
n’est pas obligé de les enfin quoi qu'au
bout de trois fois elles deviennent
pérennes mais on sait pas on va donc
quid de l'avenir demain si je mets en
difficulté mon entreprise bah là il y
aura plus de d'augmentation salaire non
plus à donner puisque l'entreprise sera
morte mais je pense que c'est avec
plaisir que les dirigeants font des
augmentations de salaire
et s'ils ne peuvent pas c'est pas de
gaieté de coeur c'est qu'ils ont un
business à gérer tout simplement et
comme tu le disais Samia tout à l'heure
et jusqu'où on met l'acceptation le
niveau d'acceptation du paiement d'une
prestation parce que là c'est bien tout
augmente les matières premières
augmentent alors donc ça serait percute
mais à un moment le consommateur
il pourra plus payer et il ne voudra
plus payer parce que quand il aura payé
une prestation je sais pas moi 100 euros
l'année dernière il voudra pas la payer
200 euros l'année prochaine parce qu'il
comprendra pas et il n'acceptera pas non
plus et là on entrera aussi dans des
difficultés
les choses soient très claires sur le
laini dont je parle ça on peut étendre
des accords d'ailleurs avec les
syndicats de salariés sur ce sujet qui
préféreront toujours une augmentation
fixe et pérenne des salaires plutôt que
ce que vous appelez prime
moi je me bats pour faire connaître
depuis des années les outils que toutes
les entreprises peuvent utiliser c'est
autoriser certaines c'est obligatoire
mais toutes les entreprises peuvent
utiliser le système de la participation
le système de l'intéressement et dans ce
cas-là c'est pas à charger donc là on
n'est pas gêné par les charges et c'est
pas pérenne ça correspond à la santé de
l'entreprise quand l'entreprise est en
bonne santé et qu'elle fait de la
richesse tout le monde contribue et
c'est la logique d'ailleurs qu'on voit
très souvent dans les entreprises et en
particulier les plus petites si j'ai des
souches donne des primes sauf qu'en plus
les primes elles sont chargées donc
effectivement ça alourdit énormément ce
système là doit absolument être
généralisé
parce que au moins exactement et partout
où on peut le mettre en place partout où
on peut le diffuser c'est un c'est un
espace de de dialogue social quand les
entreprises sont grandes et qui a des
syndicats c'est tout simplement un
espace de dialogue humain dans les plus
petites entreprises et on se dit oui à
regarder l'entreprise pour tourner elle
a besoin de gagner temps voilà dès qu'on
va passer au dessus
vous aurez ça voilà et je vous fabriquer
un demi treizième mois ou un 13e mois ou
un 13e mois et demi et c'est comme ça
que ça fonctionnera alors
je vous demande pas de me dire merci
mais en revanche quand l'entreprise ira
pas bien ça va concerner avec ma gueule
parce que vous demanderez pas l'argent
mais ça permet d'instaurer un dialogue
assez positif et constructif pour que
chacun soit intégré sur le même bateau
dans le monde de l'entreprise ces outils
là ont été freinés dans leur mise en
place clairement par les syndicats
patronaux parce qu'il considéraient que
ça pouvait créer une charge
supplémentaire même si il avait pas de
charge sociale par dessus et les
syndicats de salariés parce qu'il
considérait qu'ils veulent toujours
mieux une augmentation de salaire
pérenne que de salaire variables voilà
et je comprends les deux positions la
prudence des patrons l'ambition des
syndicats il se trouve que comme on
bouge pas
mais il se passe rien donc il vaut mieux
utiliser ces outils qui existent déjà
dans la loi il y a pas besoin de
légiférer il y a juste à mettre en place
et maintenant en plus il y a un accord
national qui a été signé sur le sujet
faisons-le et c'est quelque chose qui va
nous nous changer la vie ensemble dans
le monde de l'entreprise j'ajoute que
dans les collectivités locales il y a
des travaux qui ont essayé aussi
réalisés pour que on puisse avoir aussi
des sortes de d'intéressement sur la
qualité de service sur la productivité
des services publics sur le le la
qualité appréciée par le les usagers et
c'est très utile aussi pour que enfin on
redonne un sens à ce qui au départ était
le régime indemnitaire et que plus
personne n'utilise assez fin là
Fabien une remarque deux questions très
rapides on s'interroge sur le sens du
travail il y a 25 30 ans il y avait un
livre qui a fait polémique qui
s'appelait la fin du travail que
certains avaient peut-être lu d'ailleurs
et qui d'ailleurs dans sa version
française était préfacée par Rocard je
vous invite à lire ça c'est assez
surprenant bon évidemment c'était pas ça
l'issue de l'histoire mais s'interroger
sur le sens du travail on sait depuis
longtemps qu'on va vers une un mouvement
compliqué sur ce qu'elle travaille pour
moi il y a deux hiatus premièrement il y
a au niveau de la question du diplôme de
ce qu'est un diplôme aujourd'hui
tu as cité Olivia un certain nombre de
philosophes dans les années 30 Paul
Valéry pour fonder le diplôme en
expliquant qu'en fait on avait préféré
une espèce de socle minimum à la
formation de l'esprit et qu'on avait un
double mensonge on faisait croire aux
zinc avec ça ils avaient un droit au
travail alors que il comprenait pas
pourquoi il trouvait pas du travail
alors qu'ils avaient passé leur diplôme
et les tasses disaient bah regarder on a
90% de réussite tout va bien ça devrait
aller bien bon c'était 1935 donc je
pense que on n'a pas fini cette mutation
aujourd'hui sur ce qu'est un diplôme
je vous interroge sur le sujet mais moi
qui suis prof c'est c'est quelque chose
je vois quotidiennement deuxièmement
dans mon métier de prof je demande à mes
élèves en première deuxième troisième
quatrième cinquième année post-bac qui a
créé sa boîte
dès la première année d'émin se lèvent
dans la cinquième année parfois la
moitié de la classe c'est j'enseigne
dans la communication
est-ce que là aussi le sens du travail
dépend vraiment de la structure
moléculaire de l'entreprise on parle de
l'ubérisation je passe pas trop ce mot
là mais la réalité c'est qu'aujourd'hui
on crée sa voix que quand on crée sa
boîte on est seul que quand on est seul
on n'a pas les mêmes relations de
travail même si on se retrouve à 5-6
indépendants pour former une équipe et
ben on voilà le travail c'est pas la
santé dans ce cas là à mon avis pour
citer l'inverse de ce que disait un
chanteur français je crois que dans ces
moments-là le travail c'est plus la
santé en fait donc il faut aussi qu'on
se questionne sur ce développement
fulgurant de ce qui est très bien les
auto-entreprises les micro-entreprises
etc que les jeunes créés et qui
modifient profondément à mon avis le
sens du travail
c'est un sujet quand le numérique parce
que un collaborateur sur deux en
nouvelle-aquitaine est effectivement un
indépendant sous une forme ou sous une
autre et je le disais tout à l'heure on
a ce sujet au niveau des écoles
notamment où il y a une proportion très
significative des diplômés qui ne qui ne
finissent pas dans les entreprises qui
pour autant payent l'école
c'est à deux chiffres et c'est sérieux
et sur certaines géographies ça prend
des proportions importantes et c'est une
préoccupation toute cette population
d'indépendants
et moi au niveau des entités que je
préside on s'y attache énormément et
dans la commission paritaire où on
retrouve les syndicats d'ailleurs c'est
une préoccupation parce qu'on ne veut
pas que ça finisse comme une un saut
pour les terrias victime de niveau de
sous-traitance et toutes ces sortes de
choses on s'attache notamment très fort
à les ramener vers la formation et à
leur montrer qu'ils ont accès à la
formation et mettre en place des petits
pour qui se forment et qui soient pas
pareil balayé par l'évolution de
l'évolution technique qui qui devant
après il y a des allers-retours il y a
des gens qui étaient qui repassent
salariés qui redeviennent indépendant
mais c'est une très grande préoccupation
et en toute cette cause dans l'univers
qui est le mien c'est c'est une forte
proportion du de la population qui se
retrouve dans dans ces statuts alors ça
se retrouve dans d'autres filières
professionnelles etc effectivement il y
a pas que des salariés et c'est très
important de ne pas les oublier de s'en
occuper et la la précarisation aussi du
petit patronat si je peux me permettre
enfin des c'est aussi une procréation
parce que le chef d'entreprise aussi la
droit à la formation il a droit à
évoluer il cotise d'ailleurs pour la
formation ils l'utilise pas donc c'est
ça fait partie des sujets qui sont qui
sont qui sont en pleine chose quoi voilà
donc il faut voilà faut remarquer tout
le monde en fait c'est extrêmement
important
un très grand merci on n'aura pas le
temps de prendre toutes les questions là
de manière filmée mais en revanche on
peut continuer la discussion on va le
faire ah vous voulez oui oui on m'impose
un timing de la salle mes cheveux ok
donc on a encore deux questions alors
vous et puis mademoiselle derrière ok
donc on laisse tourner on ok non non
mais bien sûr non non ok on est alors on
est alors ok on est maître des horloges
allez-y
alors
depuis le depuis que ce que j'écoute on
ne parle pas de temps de travail
et ça ça me surprend parce que
on veut continuer le temps de travail et
qu'avec ça qu'on le travail qu'on créera
de la richesse on a beau m'expliquer ce
qu'on voudra c'est par le travail qu'on
crée la richesse on veut garder un
régime social
qui existait quand on travaillait 50
heures par semaine moi j'en suis témoin
en travaillant deux fois moins
donc là il y a une véritable réflexion
alors si on augmente les salaires
on nourrit l'inflation et c'est ce que
j'ai entendu tout à l'heure madame
vous avez dit que vous aviez des limites
pour augmenter vos prestations
donc la seule solution
c'est d'augmenter la durée du temps de
travail
ça ne me trappe plus d'inflation ça
permettra aux salariés d'avoir
des rémunérations supérieures et de
revenir à 39 heures je crois pas que ce
soit quelque chose qui soit à mon avis
déprimant ou dévalorisant ça c'était ma
question la deuxième question vous
parliez des vous parler
des aides publiques enfin de
l'intervention de l'aide publique alors
l'aide publique c'est un vaste problème
parce que on la veut quand on la veut
mais quand on en a besoin on voudrait
bien qu'elle vienne alors je m'explique
par exemple quand tu es le covid
heureusement qu'il y a eu notre public
quand il y a eu la régulation de
de l'inflation sur le sur les délais sur
l'électricité sur beaucoup de choses on
avait bien besoin de la publicité quand
on veut demander des aides de Madame
tout à l'heure vous disiez ça serait
bien que quand nous aide
sur les salaires si si on peut pas
augmenter je peux pas augmenter par
contre si je veux augmenter mon salaire
j'aimerais bien qu'on m'aide donc ça
c'est l'intervention de l'aide publique
je pourrais il y a des subventions les
publics intervient au niveau des
collectivités je suis élu je suis ancien
chef d'entreprise je suis élu et donc
les collectivités l'aide publique à
l'intervient quand même que ce soit dans
les aides dans l'investissement dans les
aides dans les créations
d'infrastructures etc etc donc je pense
qu'il faudrait il faudrait qu'on essaie
de trouver un certain équilibre au
niveau de l'intervention publique voilà
merci de m'avoir écouté
bonsoir merci tout d'abord pour vos
contributions et partage d'expérience
je crois que j'ai la dernière question
donc elle va être un peu
transversale mais
à quel échec pense-t-on le sens du
travail est-ce que finalement c'est une
aventure humaine une quête qui serait
dont on aurait le sentiment qu'elle
serait renouvelée dans une période post
covid ou est-ce que c'est une réflexion
beaucoup plus collective qu'on mène
d'ailleurs ensemble qui fait aussi que
aujourd'hui on a ce débat là sur cette
thématique là et pourquoi je pose cette
question
en ouverture c'est aussi pour réfléchir
au levier qui vont faire qu'à un moment
donné il y aura une adéquation entre le
sens individuel qui est donné au travail
et une réponse collective
des entreprises et donc parmi ces
leviers d'action qui ont parfois paru un
petit peu
comment dire ne pas avancer de manière
commune il y a l'échelle de l'entreprise
bien sûr et la question du rôle de
l'État de sa place de régulateur et je
voulais ouvrir également au niveau de
l'entreprise et poser une question sur
une fonction qui a été peu abordée mais
qui est la fonction RH dans les
entreprises qui aujourd'hui accompagnent
la transformation et aussi le besoin
qu'il y a de voir ce professionnaliser
cette fonction RH donc voilà c'est un
peu transverse mais peut-être si vous
pouvez réagir rapidement sur ce point je
vous remercie
merci merci beaucoup à tous les deux sur
la fonction RH je vous suis et surtout
les petits sont pas assez sont pas
outillés ils recrutent pas bien il
fidélise pas bien
dans sa vieille ils ignorent toutes les
dispositifs qui pourraient utiliser des
fiscalisés ou autres etc oui c'est
complètement vrai c'est quand même un
souci parce que ça veut dire que il faut
attendre une certaine entreprise pour
pouvoir se doter de ce type de fonction
moi dans mon domaine on essaie de
travailler de la mutualisation et
essayer de faire des choses pour que
pour que des strates plus petites
accèdent à ça et je reviens sur le sur
les indépendants qui eux alors sont
encore à une autre dimension mais oui
c'est extrêmement important et et on a
une image d'ailleurs assez comment dire
remplissent de lieu commun sur le sur le
DRH et DRH très très éloigné de la
réalité concrète de ce métier qui est
qui est noble et qui est très très
important effectivement pour arriver à
faire avancer un certain nombre de
choses
et donc chacun me regarde pour répondre
à la question incendiaire sur le temps
de travail je vais prendre à peu près
une heure une heure 15
et moi comme ancien chef d'entreprise
j'ai un réflexe qui est à peu près comme
le tien enfin voilà il y a un moment
seul le travail produit de la richesse
tout travail mérite salaire mais tout
salaire mérite travail enfin des choses
qui paraissent assez de bon sens
je vais faire une observation qu'on a
peut-être pas suffisamment utilisé quand
il y a eu ces grandes crises sociales
liées à la retraite parce que le temps
de travail c'est le temps de travail
dans la semaine mais c'est aussi le
temps de travail au cours de la vie
c'est la même chose si on veut produire
de la richesse et financer notre modèle
de protection sociale et l'améliorer
parce que on a très vite besoin d'une
cinquième branche pour la vieillesse bon
et la dépendance
je vais rappeler un chiffre
nous vivons 700
nous travaillons 70 000 heures
et donc ça permet de dégonfler le sujet
du temps de travail qui voilà finalement
on a mis quand même un sacré bordel dans
ce pays sur une réforme de retraite pour
décider à la fin qu'on allait travailler
tous entre 500 et 600 heures de plus par
rapport à ce qu'on fait aujourd'hui sur
une vie de 700 000 heures
dans lesquelles on utilise que 10% à
travailler
donc sur ces sujets là je veux le dire
parce que ça permet de relativiser à la
fois de mettre de la modestie dans ce
qu'on vient tout ce qu'on vient de se
dire et puis ça permet de
désenflammer le sujet du temps de
travail
ce que nous constatons partout et
partout avec aussi bien des experts
philosophes que des experts
d'entreprises que des grandes
entreprises ou des petites c'est que au
moment où nous arrivons de l'évolution
du monde économique et de la société
française il ne sera plus possible et il
serait même contre-productif voir
injuste de faire de légiférer sur le
temps de travail de façon uniforme et
nationale
parce que selon les secteurs d'activité
en réalité il y a des personnes qui
grâce à la numérisation ne travaillent
plus que 10 heures par semaine pour
faire ce qui était fait auparavant sur
quand au contraire dans d'autres
branches on a gagné beaucoup moins de
productivité c'est d'ailleurs un des
problèmes principaux de l'économie de
pays de l'OCDE c'est qu'en fait depuis 7
ans maintenant ça fait la 7e année
consécutive on n'a plus de gain de
productivité et c'est ça le vrai sujet
du financement et donc il y a des
secteurs d'activité ou oui nous
pourrions travailler plus je vous en
donne maintenant je peux élu je peux
dire que des gros mots les médecins
généralistes pourraient travailler plus
ils ne veulent pas forcément mais il y a
peut-être une négociation à opérer avec
eux enfin voilà moi qui était mère je
j'ai été confronté comme plein d'entre
vous dans vos familles dans vos vies
dans vos mairies enfin moi j'avais 4mins
qui sont partis à la retraite tous
ensemble je les ai remplacés par 8
médecins ils font moins d'heures que les
quatre qui viennent de partir et je le
comprends parfaitement d'ailleurs parce
que ils ont pas envie de faire les
médecins de campagne comme on le faisait
auparavant maintenant c'est une
profession qui a redécouvert ce qui
était les joueurs de la famille de
l'Éducation des Loisirs ils ont pas
nécessairement envie de bosser comme des
chiens mais je crois qu'on est quand
même devant un vrai problème sanitaire
en France
qui même avait en ayant débloqué le
numerus clausus on va mettre 10 ans à la
régler et donc négocier ne serait-ce que
10% de temps de travail en plus pour les
médecins généralistes permettraient à
chacun d'avoir un médecin référent ce
qui me paraîtrait pas rien dans la 5e
puissance mondiale
il y a des pays il y a d'autres métiers
où les gens peuvent travailler plus et
de façon volontaire et c'est l'idée à
mon avis des idées les plus
intéressantes qui avaient été sorties
par le Président de la République
pendant la campagne présidentielle
c'était le fait qu'on puisse avoir un
temps de travail choisi au cours de la
vie et en fonction de sa carrière parce
que selon les moments où on est malade
où on a une personne âgée à s'occuper on
a des enfants élevés ou au contraire on
a envie d'investir parce qu'on veut
s'acheter une petite maison ou parce que
on veut partir un peu mieux en vacances
ou qu'on a besoin d'aider ces enfants à
faire des études ou à grandir dans la
vie quand ils deviennent adultes et ben
on puisse de temps en temps avoir cette
possibilité au cours de la vie de dire
bah moi maintenant j'ai décidé de
travailler 45 heures ou au contraire je
vais je vais travailler 30 heures
et donc
en fixant des maximum
et des minimum
que dans chaque branche que dans chaque
secteur d'activité et ce que je dis là
et pas une grande invention
c'est ce qu'on a tous fait au moment des
35 heures le BTP a pas négocié parce que
le BTP est jamais passé à 35 heures il a
fait 38 d'autres ont négocié 35 d'autres
ont négocié des expérimentations à 32 et
en fait je pense qu'il faut juste
arriver à remettre de la liberté dans la
négociation économique et sociale et se
dire en fonction de l'entreprise les
Allemands font ça merveilleusement
Volkswagen un exemple parfait il y a une
quinzaine d'années
on remet de la liberté dans le temps de
travail et donc tu as même si je serai
enclin à suivre ton propos et à dire on
a besoin en fait seulement de créer plus
de richesses dans ce pays de cocagne qui
a la France
et on redeviendrait peut-être des
leaders mondiaux
et on parviendrait à préserver le modèle
que le monde entier cite en exemple même
si nous on a l'impression de vivre un
cauchemar permanent que dans ce pays
ultralibéral tout va mal et les gens
mangent plus et voilà non mais on a un
modèle qui nous faut préserver mais
au lieu de le faire de façon uniforme
il faut le faire dans la confiance des
acteurs économiques et moi j'ai envie de
parier sur cette confiance et ça le pas
que le sens du travail c'est le sens des
conférences qu'on a tenu
un très grand merci à vous tous et
encore merci Marie-Ève et Vincent pour
se débat